The course you're about to watch is about pointers
in C. The course was developed by the excellent
instructors from my code school. My Code School is
one of the earliest software channels on YouTube,
and has inspired many developers and creators.
In the description. I've included a link to an
article about the channels amazing story.
Now let's get to the course. pointer
is a very fundamental and important concept in
programming. But a lot of beginner programmers
find it difficult to understand pointers. So in
this lesson, we will try to demystify pointers.
And all you need to know to understand this
lesson is how to write a basic C program,
how to declare a variable and how to do
simple arithmetic upon those variables.
Okay, so let's get started. To understand
pointers, we first should understand how
various data types or various variables are stored
in computer's memory. Okay, so let us say, this
figure in the right here is computer's memory. And
when we talk about computer's memory in context of
program execution, we mostly talk about
the random access memory or the RAM,
we often say that my machine has got two GB of
two gigabytes of RAM, or four gigabyte of RAM.
Now let's say these segments, or partitions that
we are showing here in the memory is each one byte
of memory. Now in a typical memory architecture
in a typical computer architecture of the memory,
each byte of the memory has an address. So let's
say the first byte in this memory, which we can
assume to be the lowest by deep down here has an
address zero and the address keeps on increasing
as we go towards the top. So we go on like 012.
And let's assume this particular address is
201. So the next byte will have an address of 202.
And we will go on like 203204, and so on. Now,
when we declare a variable in our program, let's
say for example, if we declare a variable a of
type integer, then when this program executes,
the computer allocates some amount of memory
corresponding to this particular variable.
How much memory it allocates, depends upon
the data type, and also upon the compiler. So
in a typical modern day compiler and integer
is allocated four bytes of memory. Character
variable is allocated one byte of memory,
float is allocated four bytes of memory and
we can have other variables as well. Okay,
so as soon as the computer sees a declaration,
like this, during the program's execution,
it knows that this is an integer variable, so
we need to allocate four bytes of memory. Let's
say in our example, it allocates memory starting
address 2042 address 2074 a. And the computer has
an internal structure, a lookup table, where it
stores this information that there is a variable
a, it is of type integer, and it is located at
address 204, which is the starting address of
the variable. Now, if we declare another variable,
so for example, if we declare a variable named C,
which is of type character, now once again,
when the machine sees this declaration,
it knows that it is a character variable, so it
needs one byte of memory. So it looks for some
free space, let's say in this case, it allocates
the address to 09 the byte 2094 C, and once again,
it keeps an entry for it in an internal structure
called lookup table, that a sees a character
and its addresses 209. Now when we perform some
operation with these variables, like let's say
if we initialize a to five, when our machine or
computer sees such a statement, it looks into
the lookup table for this variable A. So it finds
this variable a that it is an integer and it is
at address 204. So, it goes at address 204 and in
these four bytes starting 204 it writes this value
five now in reality, the value is written in
binary but for the sake of understanding we
are writing here in decimal form. Now once again,
let's say we have some statements and then again
after these statements, we have another statement
which increments a Now again, when computer sees
that, he has to be incremented, it again looks
for this address for a goes to the address and
modifies this value at this particular address.
So this block of memory allocated for a stores
the value six now. Now, all of this is really
cool, but can we know the address of a variable
In our program, or can we operate upon
these memory addresses in our program?
Well, yes, you can do so in a C or c++ program
using the concept of pointers. pointers are
variables that store the address of another
variable. And to make you understand about this
a little better, I'll redraw a couple of these
things. Let us say we have a block of four bytes
at address two sort of food that stores an integer
variable a. Now we can have another variable,
the type of which is pointer to integer. And
let us say the name of this variable is P.
Now this variable p can store the address of
A. And using the properties of P, or using some
operators upon p, we can reach a. Now p also
takes some memory. So let's say it is stored
at location address 64. And it also takes four
bytes of memory, we can also modify p to point to
another integer. So let's say if we
have another integer at address 208,
named B and having value 10. And if we change the
address in p from 2042208, then P now points to
me. Let us now see the syntax of pointer variables
and see a normal variable is declared by writing
the data type and a variable name. So int a means
that we have a variable a of type int. If we want
to write a pointer variable that should point to
another variable, all we do is we put an Asterix
sign before the variable. So P is now a pointer
variable that points to an integer. So P is a
variable that can store the address of an integer.
Now, to store the address of A in p, we need to
use a statement like p is equal to ampersand a.
Now if we put ampersand in front of a variable,
it gives us the address of that particular
variable. In fact, it returns a pointer
to that particular variable. Okay, so let's try
to see a simulation of this. Let's say when we
declared the variable A, then it was allocated an
address to zero for now we declare an a pointer to
integer p, let's say it was allocated
at a 64. Now when we write a statement,
like p is equal to ampersand A, then P now has
the address of A and it kind of points to a.
Let's initialize a to some value let's say is
equal to five, so we fill value five into a now.
Now, what will happen if I print p, what will
be the output? Any guesses? Think about it.
Okay, so if we try to print p, then the output
will be 204 because P has a value to 04. What if
we simply try to print ampersand of a ampersand
of a also gives us the address of a so this will
also be 204. What if we want to print ampersand
of P. Now P is also a variable and it is also
stored in the memory. So ampersand since it prints
the it gives you the address of that variable.
So, printing ampersand of P should give us
64 which is the address of P. Now, there is
one more important property of pointer, if we
put an asterisk sign in front of the pointer,
then it gives us the value at
the location that it points to.
So, what will happen if we try to print star
of P asterik of p? Well, it will give us
five This concept is called as D referencing
because we have a reference or we have stored
an address in P and we kind of get the value
at this particular address using this operator.
In fact, we can modify the value at this
particular location by saying something
like Star P is now eight star p means value at p
and so, the value at p is now modified to eight.
So, what will happen if you print star p
or print a now the output will be eight
by value of p i mean value at address P.
So P is the address and star P is the value
at address that is stored in P. Okay, so just
to reiterate, we define a pointer variable
using by putting an asterisk sign
in front of the variable name.
And if we put an ampersand sign in front of
a variable name, we get the address of it.
So if we try to print a pointer variable without a
strict sign or operate upon it without astrix I We
are operating with the address, while if we put
an Asterix and in front of the pointer variable
and operate upon it, then we are
operating the value at that address.
So this was some of the basics of pointers. In the
coming lessons, we will see some code snippets,
where we will see some of the common errors that
we make while using pointers. And we will also
learn pointer arithmetic and pointers in the
context of arrays. So, thanks for watching.
So, in our previous lesson, Introduction to
pointers, we learned the basics of pointers. In
this lesson, we will see how to work with pointers
in some real code examples. But before that
a quick recap, pointers are variables that store
address of other variables. We declare a normal
normal variable with a syntax like
the data type or the variable type,
followed by the variable name, but we declare
a pointer variable with a syntax data type and
an Asterix sign followed by the variable
name, we need an integer pointer variable
to store the address have an integer to store the
address of say, a character variable we will need
a character pointer so the same syntax
will be used we put an asterisk sign
and let's say the name of the variable is P zero.
So C is a character variable and P naught is a
pointer to character. And similarly, we can have
a pointer to double. And we can also have pointers
to a user defined structure or a user defined
class also. And to get the address of a variable
we write a statement like p is equal to ampersand
a now this ampersand works as an operator, that
gives us the address of A. And what happens in the
memory is something like this. Variable p stores
the address of variable A. So in this figure
here, PS value is 204, which is the address of a
so P points to a and using p we can also get the
value of A. So let's say if A is eight, and we
use a star operator in front of p, then the star
p gives us eight which is value of A. If we try
to print stoppie it gives us eight. Let us now
try to see some of these in real code. Okay,
so time to see things moving in a real C program.
Now, what I'll do is I'll play a game with you, I
will write some print statements, and you need to
guess what will be the output. So what I'll first
do is I'll declare an integer variable a, and
then I'll declare another variable which will be
pointed to integer. And now I'll write a
print statement where I'll be printing P. Now,
what will be the output of this program? Okay,
so let's run this program. Oops, this gives us
an error. And if it is too small for you to read,
then this is giving an error that the variable P
is not initialized. And we are using it without
initializing. So that's why the program is
crashing. So now I will write a statement p
is equal to ampersand a now ampersand of A is
nothing but address of A. Now let's run this
again. Okay, so this springs and address
and how do we know that this is the address or
this is the right address that is stored in P.
So I'll write another print statement. And now I
am printing star p now star operator when it is
put in front of that dress then it gives
us the value at that particular address.
Okay, so what will be the output of the second
print statement? So when we done this, the the
first line gives us the address that points to
and this address is different than the previous
address because every time the program runs afresh
new addresses are located. But the value at B
is some garbage value is some
integer that I'm not sure what it is.
This is happening because I have not initialized
a and all the memories are located for a there is
some garbage value there that I do not know
about. Okay, so let's initialize a let's say
a is equal to 10. And now the
second line prints the value of a
and now I will write another print statement. And
this time I'll print ampersand a. Now what should
be the output of this third print statement?
And this should be pretty easy to guess.
ampersand operator gives us the address And that's
why the third line is also the address of A.
In fact, that's what we have done
here, when we have assigned p,
the address of A, we have
used operator and percent.
Now what I will do is, I will modify the value in
a using the pointer P. And to do so I will write a
statement like Star p is equal to 12. And this is
read as value at address p value at address being
pointed by B is now 12. This concept is called
dereferencing. So, now, if I try to print a,
and let's also put one print statement for
a before we modify the value, and let's
run this. So the first print gives me 10, which
is the value that we had initialized a with
and the second print gives us a is equal
to 12. Because we modified the value
using the pointer. Okay, so one more thing that
I'll do here, now, I'll have another variable b,
that will have value 20. And now what I'll say
is start p or value at address p is equal to b.
And the question now is that will the
address and P change now 2.2 b? Well,
no, unless you explicitly write a
statement like b is equal to ampersand b,
this reverse operation will not happen,
what we are doing here is actually only
putting in the address of a the value that B
has, but we are not pointing to B. And this
will get clear only if we write some more printf
statements. So before writing the statement,
I'm writing two print statements, one to
print the address and one to print the value.
And after we write the statement, I'll write two
more print statements trying to print the address
and value again. So, let us see what output is
now okay. So, address of P initially is t 144576
and value is 10. And after the statement star p
is equal to b only the value is modified and the
pointer still points to a. So a kind of now
becomes 20, but the address does not change.
Now, one more thing, sometimes we declare and
initialize a variable in the same statement.
So instead of writing this A equal 10, here,
we could simply say that int a is equal to 10.
So we can do so for the pointer
variable as well, we could simply say
for these two statements, one simple statement
like n star p is equal to m percent a and we
will not need the statement. This one statement
is same as saying the earlier two statements,
the syntax of declaring pointers some people write
this asterisk sign after end and do not write it
in front of the variable name. This also works
and this is also fine. So you can write int
star which which means pointer to integer
and then you can write the variable name
and this will also work. Okay, so now we
will point we will talk about a concept.
We will talk about the
concept of pointer arithmetic.
But before that I'll write this rewrite this
declaration and initialization like before
in two statements. I like it better this way,
it's less confusing. Now I will write two print
statements here. In the first statement,
I'll print P and in another statement,
I will print p plus one. Now is it really possible
to do so? Can we really increment and decrement
a pointer variable? Well, yes, we can do so. So
now let's assume that the address stored in P is
something like 2002. So any guesses what
p plus one will be? Will it be 2003?
Well, no p plus one will be 2006. This is because
if p is an integer pointer incrementing it by one
unit takes us to the address of the next integer.
And because the size of an integer is four bytes.
So to go to the next integer address, we need to
skip four bytes. So P plus one increments p by
four bytes, I'll write another print statement in
which I'll print the size of an integer variable.
And I'll write something like size of integer is
and we have a function and see size of that gives
us the size of a data type. So this statement this
print statement will give us the size of integer
and let's write in the first and
third print statement something like
address P is blah and address p plus one is a
block. So let's now run this and see what happens
okay. So the output is address P is 4586052 which
is some address. And then we print size of integer
is four bytes. So for this Particular compiler,
the size of an integer is four bytes and address
p plus one is four bytes more than address p, you
can try this thing out for a character pointer or
a double pointer or a pointer of some other data
type. Okay, so we could also increment this by
two. And what happens if we increment this by two?
Well, it will increment the address by eight. So
this will be like 2010 plus two will be 2010.
And this 2002 and 2010 is something that I've
picked up randomly, just for the sake of example.
Okay, so now once again, what if I want to print
the value at this particular address, so I'm
printing two more lines here now I'm printing
that value at address P is and I'll print star
p, which gives us the value at that address.
And we will print another line that will say that
value at address p plus one is and there should
be star p plus one, we put the star operator in
front of the address Okay. So now what will be the
output, okay, so, the output is that address P is
some address and value at address P is 10, which
is alright, because we had stored the address
of variable a in P. Now, next time the size
of integer is four bytes, and p plus one is four
more than that recipe. and the value at address p
plus one is some integer value that I do not
know about. In fact, this has some garbage value,
because because we do not really have an integer
allocated to this particular memory address.
And this is one dangerous thing about C using
pointer arithmetic using pointer manipulation,
you can reach to any address. And sometimes
these kinds of operations can bring some unwanted
behavior to your program. I recommend trying
these things out these snippet of code with
other data types like character or float, and the
result the results will be similar. So this was
some playing around with pointers. And in
the coming lessons, we will talk more about
pointers. And we will talk about pointers in
the context of arrays. So thanks for watching.
So far, in our previous lessons, we have
seen how to work with pointer variables.
So we pretty much understand the basics. In
this lesson, we will write some more code
using pointers. And we will look through some
of these concepts. in more detail using some
examples. The first thing that I want to point
out is that pointer variables are strongly typed.
What it means is that you need a pointer variable
of a particular type to store the address of a
particular type of variable. So int star or a
pointer to integer will be needed to store the
address of an integer character pointer will
be needed to store that does have a character.
And similarly, if we have a user defined
structure or class, then we need a pointer
of that particular type only. But why do we
need these strong types? Isn't it that the
pointer variables just store the address of the
variable? So why couldn't we have just one type?
That will be some generic type to store the
address of all kinds of variables? And the answer
is that we do not use the pointer variables only
to store memory addresses. But we also use them
to dereference these addresses so that we can
access and modify the values in these addresses.
Now, as we know, data types have different sizes,
like in a typical modern day compiler and integer,
it's stored in four bytes. A character
variable is stored in one bite of float
is again stored in four bytes. And these variables
differ not only in their sizes, they also differ
in how we store information in whatever bytes are
available for these variables or data types. Let's
say we have an integer a and its value is 1025.
And this is how it is laid out in the memory each
each bracket here is one byte. So let's say this
particular byte which is the least significant
byte is byte zero, and then we go on like bite
one, bite two and by three. Now we also know that
each byte in the memory is addressable. Let's say
the address of bytes zero is 200. Now these four
bytes need to be contiguous let's say the address
of byte to byte one is 201. And then we go on like
202 and 203. When an integer is represented in the
memory is stored in the memory the leftmost bit
stores the information that whether this integer
is positive or negative, so this is also called
signed bit, signed bit and rest 31
bits are used to store the value.
So if you see we have a one at right most
bet with place value two to the power zero
and at this particular bit with place value to to
the About 10. So the overall value that we have in
binary here is one zero to five in decimal.
Now, what if I declare a pointer to integer
P and store the address of A in p
by using the ampersand operator,
what will happen if I print the value of p, the
value of p or the address stored in p will be 200,
the address of bytes zero. So we're kind of saying
that we have the address of an integer variable
starting at address 200. If we dereference
this address and try to print asterik P,
we want to know the value at this particular
address, then the machine sees that okay,
P is a pointer to integer, so we need to
look at four bytes starting address 200.
And then the machine knows that how to extract
extract the value of an integer data type.
So it really it retrieves the value one
zero to five out of this four bytes. Now,
if p was a character pointer, then while
dereferencing, the machine would have looked
at only one byte because a character variable
is only one byte. If P was appointed to float,
then although float is also stored in four bytes,
but the way information is written for float
in these four bytes is different from the way
information is returned for an integer datatype.
So the value printed would have been
something else. Let's go write some of
this in a real program and see what happens. In
my C program, I will first declare an integer A
equal to 1025. And now I'll declare a pointer
to integer P. And then I'll store the address of
A in p by using the ampersand operator. Now I'll
write a print statement like this size of integer
is, and we have a function size of NC, which gives
us the size of a particular datatype in bytes.
And now I'll write a print statement like this
address is equal to P and value is equal to
asterik p with dereference p to bring the value.
Now let us see what is the output of this program.
No points for guessing this is pretty
straightforward. The size of integer
is four bytes, the address that we are showing
here is some address and the value is 1025.
Okay, now I'll do some trick here, I'll declare
a character pointer let's say the name of the
variable is P zero. Now I'll try to put the same
address as we have in P into P zero by writing
a statement like this. But this will give us a
compilation error because p zero is a pointer to
character and p is a pointer to integer. So what
we will do here is we'll typecast p to character
pointer and then assign the value. And now I'll
write two more print statements. First is size of
character is these many bytes and use the method
size of again and the second is the address is
P zero and the value at addresses asterik p zero.
So we dereference we try to dereference p zero now
and let us see what's the output now, the first
line of output a size of integer is four bytes
address because we are running the program fresh
this address will not be the previous address that
was from the previous run this will be a different
address by dereferencing the integer pointer we
are getting the value 1025. Now the next line
of output a size of character is one byte
addresses 5373032 which is the same address as
we have in the second line, but the value of this
time is one. Now why is this value one once
again if we write 1025 in binary using 32 bits,
then this will be the representation. When
we do this typecasting here trying to store
the address of P in p zero, then the address
of this particular byte the rightmost byte
is stored in p zero. But when we dereference p
zero because p zero is a pointer to character
the machine says that hey, this is a pointer to
a character and the character is only one byte.
So I look at only one byte to see the value.
And if you see this particular byte in binary
is one and that's why this output here is one.
Okay, I'll write two more print statements now.
One to print the address p plus one and the
value at address p plus one. Now as we know
we can add or subtract in an integer constant
from a pointer variable. This is allowed in fact
the only pointer arithmetic that is allowed is
adding or subtracting some constant integer value
to the pointer. p plus one will take
us to the address of the next integer.
So it will skip four bytes and take us four bytes
ahead. Let's say we also want to print p zero plus
one and the value at V zero plus one. Okay now
let's see the output of this particular program,
the address of a this time is 4456036 that's
what is allocated for a in this particular run
the value is 1025 p plus one is 4456040 if you
see this is four bytes more than the address of A,
because size of integer is four bytes and
p is a pointer to integer So, incrementing
p takes us four bytes forward and this value is
some garbage value because we have not filled
anything in this particular address. So, there is
some garbage in the memory which we are picking up
now, the address in PS row is also 4456036
which is the address of the first byte the least
significant byte of a the value is one now, P zero
plus one is 4456037 here we have a value which is
one byte more and this is because character is
stored in one bytes. Now, the value here is four
if you see p zero plus one will take us to this
particular byte the address of this particular
byte and this particular byte in binary is four
this was to show you how things happen in memory
when we dereference a pointer variable by using
the Asterix operator and also what happens when
we perform pointer arithmetic with a particular
pointer type. This typecasting of pointer variable
from one to another also has some use cases we
will discuss them later. Now, we will discuss
one pointer type which is generic pointer type
it does not correspond to a particular data type
and this pointer type is called void pointer
and we declared this particular pointer type
by using the keyword void and using an Asterix
sign in front of the variable name okay now,
we can write something like p zero is equal to p
we do not need an explicit typecasting here like
this, the statement p zero is equal to P is valid
and this will not give you a compilation error
and because this particular pointer type
is not mapped to a particular data type,
we cannot dereference this particular pointer
variable. So, if you try to print star
P naught or astrix p not this will give you
an error we are getting a compilation error,
we can only print the address. And as we can
see here the address is same as the address of
A and if we perform arithmetic, if we try to do
something like p zero plus one access something
like p zero plus one, this is also not possible
this will also give you a compilation error,
we will come back to the
use cases of wide pointers
in forthcoming lessons. Let's for now know
that there is something called void pointers.
So this was diving deep into pointer types,
typecasting and pointer arithmetic, we will have
a lot of fun with pointers in the coming lessons.
So thanks for watching. In our lessons so far, we
have seen how we can work with pointers in some of
the basic scenarios. But there are some scenarios
where pointers can be really puzzling. And once
that scenario is when we want to use pointers to
pointers. So in this lesson, we are going to see
how we can use a pointer to pointer let us assume
that this is a logical view of computer's memory
and each partition here is one byte of memory Now,
we know that each byte of memory has an address,
we have drawn the memory horizontally here,
let us assume that the address increases as we go
from left to right. So if this byte is at address
200 the next byte would be at address 201 and
the next byte would be at address 202 and so on.
Now let's say in my program, I have
declared an integer variable named x
and maybe I have initialized it as five and now
when the program will run some amount of memory
will be allocated for this variable x. In a
typical architecture in a typical compiler
integer is stored in four bytes, so four byte
will be allocated for x. So let's say these
four bytes at address 225. This block of four
bytes starting address 225 is allocated for x.
And the values stored in this block of four bytes
for x is five. Now the next thing that I want to
do is I want to declare a pointer variable that
will store the address of x. Now to store the
address of an integer we will have to declare a
pointer to integer something like this, we need
to put an asterisk sign in front of the variable
name. Now, what will happen is that some amount
of memory will be reserved for this variable p in
a typical All architecture pointer is also stored
in four bytes. So let's say we get this block of
four bytes at address 215 for P. And now, I want
to write a statement like this. So I want to fill
in the address of x in P. And that's how p points
to x ampersand operator gives us the address
of a variable. Now one important thing here,
we are able to store the address of x in p because
P is of type pointer to integer, if p was of type
pointer to character, or pointer to some other
variable. And this statement, p equal ampersand
X would not have been valid. So if I have to write
down the types of these two variables, then x is
an integer, and p is a pointer to integer. Or I
can also say that that P is int star, int asterik.
And y pointer variables are strongly typed. Why
do we need a pointer to integer to reference
or store the address of an integer? It is because
we don't just store the address of a variable in a
pointer variable. We also use the pointer variable
to dereference that address dress and write some
value there. So if I write a statement like this,
this value here at address 225. And this x is
now modified. Now can I create a pointer to this
variable p, which itself is a pointer to integer?
Well, yes, we actually we can do so. So let's
say we want to create a variable named queue,
that will store the address of P. Now what
will be the type of this variable, we need
a pointer of a particular type to store the
address of a particular type of variable.
So to store a pointer to integer, we will
have to say that, that we want a pointer
to pointers, so we will put two Asterix sign
in front of the variable name. And now this
variable q can store the address of P. So with
this first line with this end asterik asterik q,
we created q let's say we created q at 205. And
now we are seeing that q will store the address of
P. So q points to P and the type of Q is int
asterik asterik with to be put to Asterix.
simple way to read this is that the type
of variable x is an integer. So to store
the address of x we will need a pointer of type
int star. So we will put one star to say that
this is a pointer to that particular type.
And to store the address of p we will need
a pointer to int star so we will put one extra
star to say that this is a pointer to int star.
And we can go on like this. Let's say we want
to declare a pointer to pointer to pointer so
int asterik asticus pointer to pointer and
we will put one more asterik or we can put
these three asterik immediately after this
keyword end. Or we can put it immediately
before the variable name like we have done in
the case of Q here. Let's say we define r as int
star star star. So let's say R gets this address
to 13 the memory now are is of type int asterik
astrick Asterix so it can store the address of
int asterik asterik. So, it cannot store the
address of X or P all the statements something
like r is equal to ampersand Q will be valid.
Now, I have translated my previous rough code
into a working C program. Now let us assume that
this program is working as per this memory
sketch that we are showing in the right
now I will write some print statements and you
need to get the output. So basically you have
to assume that these variables x p, q and r are
allocated these addresses what we are showing here
in the right. So the first print statement that
I'm going to write is I want to print as strict p
and this one should be simple for you asterik
p would be value stored at address in p so this
will be six. Now the next statement
that I want to print is asterik q.
So astrick q will be a value at address stored
in Q address stored in variable Q is 215. So
this is nothing but the value of p so this will be
25. And now I want to print asterik astrick q so I
want to do dereferencing twice. First I want to go
to Astra q Astra Q is this address 225 and now I
want to look at the value at address 225. So this
one will be six we could have avoided writing this
paranthesis here We could have said Astrid,
gastric que only and that would have also,
that would have meant the same. But it's a good
practice if we are using this asterik operator
to use paranthesis wherever we can do it because
sometimes, when we are also using other operators,
we are not sure about the proceedings,
and we want to avoid unwanted behaviors.
Now, what about these two print statements asterik
asterik R and Astra gastric asterik r asterik
r means value in Q which will be 215. And then
further, one more dereferencing will take us to
value in p which is 225. And one more
dereferencing will take us to value in
x which will be six. If you see this is really
interesting. From our we are using one asterik
operator and we are able to go to Q then we are
using das trick operator twice and we reach P
and then we are using the astrick operator thrice
and we reach x, let's make some more changes in
this code and run this in a real compiler. So what
I'll do here is I'll write a statement like this.
And then after this statement, I'll print the
value in x. If you run this now, as you can see,
asterik p astrochemistry q and astrochemistry
gastric are all these three values are six,
the address will not be same as we had shown in
the example for obvious reasons. And as you can
see, we are able to modify x by doing this
chain of dereferencing using this variable
r if we would write something like astrochemistry
Q is equal to let's say something like this.
Now asterik P is also referencing x and
astrochemistry Q is also dereferencing x sorry,
we are dereferencing here. So any guesses what
will be the output of this last print statement?
Well, if you see x is incremented by two
here. So this was pointed to pointer,
I recommend that you write some of this code
yourself and play a little bit in the coming
lessons we will use pointer to pointer in some
real problems scenarios. So thanks for watching.
In our previous lessons, we define pointer
variables. And we also saw how to operate
upon pointer variables how to work with pointer
variables in C or c++ program. But we did not
really talk about the real use cases of pointer
variables in watch scenarios we may want to
use pointer variables. So, in this lesson, we
will talk about one of the use cases of pointer
variables and the use cases using them using
pointers as function arguments. And we also termed
this as call by reference. So, let's discuss
a scenario all Bert is a beginner programmer,
and he has recently learned about the concept
user defined functions. Now he tries to apply
this concept and he writes a simple C
program like this, what he is trying to
achieve here is that he has an integer variable
declared and initialized in the main method
and he wants to increment the value in this
variable by one. So, instead of writing
something like a plus plus or a equal to a plus
one, instead of writing a statement like this,
he writes a function increment that will take an
integer a as argument and inside this function, he
is writing a statement like a is equal to a plus
one he calls this function increment from the main
method passing a as argument and then he prints
the value of a now what he is expecting here
is that the value of a will be incremented to
11 and hence the print statement will print a
equal leaven, but when he runs the program, the
output of the print statement is a equal 10. Now,
Albert does not understand why this is happening,
he has declared a variable a and then he has
initialized this variable to 10 and then he is
passing the same A to the function increment
and the same a is being being incremented by one
in this function. So why the value of a being
printed is not leaven. Why is it 10 now,
what Albert does not understand well,
or what he probably forgot, is that whenever
we declare a variable inside a function,
then we call that variable a local variable,
because as such, just using the variable name,
we can access that variable only inside the same
function in which we have declared the variable.
So these two a this a in the function
increment and this a In the function main,
are actually not the same a, the A in
the function increment is another a,
when main calls the method increment and passes
this a as argument to the function, then only the
value of a is copied to this another A, which is
another variable local to the increment function.
So what I'll do is I'll do couple of modifications
in this code to show you a better picture.
I will write two print statements in
this code. First print statement in the
increment method something like this address
of variable a in increment is and as we know,
if we put ampersand operator in front of the
variable name, then we get the address of that
variable. And I'll comment out this print and I'll
write one more print in the main method like this.
And here I print that address of variable a in
Maine is ampersand a. Let us now run this and see
what happens. Let me also put an end of line after
we print the statement. And the output is address
of variable a in increment method is printed as
4454460. And in Maine, it is equal to 4454660.
This two looks similar, but they're not the same.
One is having 4460 and then and another time 4660.
What the values are is not important, what
the addresses are is not important. What's
important is that these addresses are different.
If the A in main method and the A increment method
was same, these two addresses would have
been same. To understand this even better,
we will try to understand how things happen in
computer's memory when a program executes when
a program or an application is started, then the
computer sets aside the machine sets aside or
reserves some amount of memory for the execution
of this program. The memory that is set aside
for the application is divided into is typically
divided into these four parts that we are showing
here one part of memory is allocated to store
the various instructions in the program, the
computer needs to keep all these instructions in
the memory these instructions that we have in the
program like increment or declare these variables
all these sequential instructions, one part of the
memory is one part of the allocated memory is for
static or global variables. If we do not declare
a variable inside a function in c++ or C then
it is a global variable. Now global variables
can be accessed and modified anywhere in the
program unlike local variables, which can be
accessed and modified within a particular
function or within a particular code block.
Now, the third part of the applications memory
is called as stack and this is really important,
this is where all the local variables go and we
will mostly be talking about stack in this lesson.
And the fourth part the fourth part is heap. And
we will come to this later in in our forthcoming
lessons have these four segments of the allocated
memory the text segment, the global variable
segment and the stack segment, these three are
fixed and they are decided when the program
starts executing the application however, can keep
asking for more memory for hits its heap segment
during its execution only. We will cover all of
these things in detail in our forthcoming lessons
please do not get scared by these terms.
Let us now see what happens when a program
executes. Let us say this is our computer's
overall memory, the RAM and as we know each byte
in the memory is addressable. So, let's say the
memory allocated for our program is from address
200 to 800. And these are the various segments of
our applications memory and have this let's say
address 300 to 600 is allocated for stack.
Now there is more memory of course in the ram
after address 800 and before address 200
Okay. So from 200 to 800. This part of
the memory is assigned for our program, let's
say this C program that we have in the left.
Now, when a function is invoked, like when the
program starts the main method is initially
invoked, all the information about the method
all the information about the method call
like its parameters, all the local variables,
the calling function to which it should return.
The current instruction at which it is executing.
All this information is stored in the stack. So,
we will take out from the stack some part for the
main method and create a unit which we call stack
frame, each function will have a stack frame. Now
we have a variable a now memory is allocated for a
from this stack frame and the value of a is 10.
Now, the main method calls increment function,
what happens when main method calls increment
is that the machine says that hey, I will stop
your execution for some time, I will stop at this
particular instruction let me go ahead and finish
this method increment. And then I'll come back
to the main method once I'm done with increment,
now another stack frame is allocated for the
increment method and the parameters in increment
method like we have a parameter a So, fresh local
variables are created corresponding to these
parameters and whatever values have been passed
are copied to these variables these parameters
Now, when we say a is equal to a plus one
here in this statement, then what happens that
this a which is local to the increment
function in this particular stack frame,
this is incremented we cannot access a variable it
outside it stack frame and now increment finishes
when increment finishes the control returns to
the main method and what the machine does is
it clears the stack frame that was located for
increment and main method resumes again So, main
method was paused at this particular instruction
increment. So, lifetime of a local variable is
till the time the function is executing. Now,
the next statement in main method is a call to
the function print f print F is not a user
defined function it is a library function
the state of execution of main method is
kind of paused and printf is executing now,
we often call this particular structure call stack
or function call stack whatever function is at
the top of the stack is executing and remember
this stack is fixed in size. So, if you have a
scenario where one function keeps calling another
function in dead definitly like in the case of
an infinite recursion, then the memory of this
stack will overflow and our program will crash
okay but that is not relevant for this scenario.
So, now, you must be getting a picture of what
happens when one function calls another function.
This a is in the stack frame of the main method.
Main is our calling function and increment is
our call function. When we call a function in
the calling function, the argument is also known
as actual argument and in the call function,
the argument is known as formal argument. All
that happens is the actual argument is actually
mapped to a formal argument. So, when this
function called happens a is mapped to a as an
actual argument is mapped to another A, which is a
formal argument instead of a if we were having an
x here, so, we would have written something like
in x as is the argument and x is x plus one then
a would have been mapped to x. So, the value of
a will be copied to the variable x. Now, when we
make such a function call, where we basically have
one variable being mapped to another variable that
value in one variable copied to another variable
then such a function call is also called as
call by value. So, this is what Albert was doing,
making a call by value. And that's why he was not
able to get the desired result. But can we get
the result that Albert wanted to have all but
wanted to use this variable A, which is local to
the main method inside the increment function?
Can we really do so? Well yes, we can do so,
if we use pointers as function arguments. Let
us now look at this code. And I'm drawing only the
stack here so that I'm able to show the simulation
of program execution neatly. Now, what we are
doing here is that we do not have an argument
which is integer in this function increment we
have an argument which is pointed to integer
and pointer to integer as we know we will it will
store the address of an integer. So now what we
are doing is that in the increment function, we
are passing the address of a so when the program
will start executing the main method will be
invoked First, let's say this is the stack frame
of the main method. Let's say 300 to 350. This
addresses the stack frame of main method and there
would be a local variable a. In this main method,
let's say the address at which a is stored is 308.
This may not be in proportion, but still
let's say this is how it is stored.
Now when main method calls increment, then a
local variable corresponding to the parameter P is
created. And this is a pointer to integer and the
value that is passed to this particular function.
The value that gets stored In this particular
Sorry, it's not a function, it's a variable
the value that gets copied or stored in this
particular variable would be 308 the address of A.
So P is pointing to a. Now in this statement
here when we say asterik P, we dereference
this address, so we are seeing here that asterik
P is value at address stored in p. So, we say that
increment the value stored at address p by one,
the value stored at address 308 gets incremented
by one, so, a is now 11. So, now when increment
finishes, and we come back to the main method,
and the next line gets executed,
which is the print statement,
then A is now 11. If you run this program,
then what gets printed is a equal lemon,
such a function call in which instead of passing
the value of a variable, we passed the address of
the variables so that we have a reference to the
variable and we can dereference it and perform
some operations is called call by reference.
So, if we use pointers as functions arguments,
then we are using call by reference call by
reference can save us a lot of memory because
instead of creating a copy of a large and complex
data type, if we just use a reference to it,
and using a reference will also cost us
some memory but very small amount of memory,
then, we are saved from creating a new copy of a
complex data type. In the coming lessons, we will
see more of the layout of applications memory,
and what are things we can do using pointers. So,
thanks for watching the concept of pointers and
arrays in C or c++ go together, there is a very
strong relationship between these two concepts.
And in this lesson, we will be discussing this
relationship. When we declare an array, let's
say we declare an integer array A of size five,
then we create five integer variables named is
zero, a one a two, a three and a four. Now these
five integers will be stored in the memory as a
block of five consecutive integers something like
this, what we are showing here in the right,
if a zero or the first element in the array
is stored at address, let's say address 200. And
in a typical compiler, modern day compiler integer
is stored in four bytes. So a one will be four
bytes ahead of a zero at 204. And a two will be
at 208, a three will be at 212. A four will be
at 216, the overall size of the array would be
20 bytes, and these 20 bytes will be one
consecutive block, we are only showing
the section of the memory in which a is stored.
Sometimes we also show the memory horizontally,
something like this, from left to right, we
increase the address but these two representations
are just for the sake of understanding,
let's use the horizontal representation of
the memory. And this time, I'll show this memory
a little more extending towards the right so that
I can accommodate a couple of more variables.
Let's say apart from this integer array, I have
an integer variable x and its value is five. And
let's say x is located at address 300. Now, let's
say I have a pointer to integer P and P, I store
the address of x if we print p then the value
in p would be 300. So, this statement will print
300 and if we dereference P and try to print the
address stored in Try to print the values stored
in this location p then the value would be five
this is fine. But we also know that
we can do an operation something like
increment or decrement a pointer variable
by a constant. So we can do something like
p equal p plus one and this will take
us to the address of the next integer
and because integer is four bytes, so now p would
be 304. So if I want to print p now, then the
output should be 304. But if we try to dereference
p now and try to print Asterix p then we do not
know the value at this address. So we cannot say
what will be printed. It's like we know that Mr.
X lives at address 300 but we do not know who is
his neighbor who lives at address through 304.
But for this integer array A, let us say I'm
writing the same integer array in right here,
which is located at address 200. If I declare a
pointer to integer P and store the address of the
first element by putting an ampersand operator
In front of a zero, then printing p would give
us in this scenario, the output 200 and printing
astrak p would give us. But before that, let's
say we have these values in the array,
let's fill up some values in the array.
So Asterix p would be two. Now if I want to
print p plus one, then the address would be
204. And if I dereference p plus one, and try
to print this value, then it will be four.
And similarly if we wanted the third element
in the array, we could do a p plus two here.
So using pointer arithmetic makes sense in the
case of pointers, because in the case of arrays,
because we know what is in the adjacent location,
there is one more property of the array,
if we just use the name of the array A, then a
gives us the pointer to the first element in the
array. So we can write a statement like p is equal
to a, in fact, we do not even need to take this
address in another pointer variable. If we simply
print a then this gives us nothing but the address
of the first element in the array. And if we want
to dereference this and try to print asterik A,
then this will give us the value. So if we want
to perform something like we want to print a plus
one, then this will give us the address to 04 and
asterik, a plus one will give us the address of
the second element in the array value of the
second element in the array. For an element
in the array. at index i we can retrieve the
address of this particular element in the memory
using either ampersand AI, or simply a plus i
and these two will give us the address of AI and
the value of AI can be retrieved using either we
simply use AI, or we can also use Asterix a plus i
an Asterix a plus I will also give us the value.
Now this is an important concept, we can write
ampersand AI or a plus i for each other and they
mean the same. And we can write a AI or Asterix a
plus AI for each other and they mean the same. The
address of the first element in the array can also
be called the base address. And a simply using
the variable name a gives us the base address
of the array. Let us now see some code examples
and try to solidify our concepts further.
In my program, let's say we have an integer
array A. Now as I said, if we simply print
a then this should give us the address
of the first element in the array.
And we can also get the address of the first
element in the array by using ampersand operator
in front of a zero. If I simply print a zero
it will print the first element in the array
and we can also print the first element in the
array by using Asterix operator in front of
the variable name a. Let us now run this and see
what happens. And I also need to put an end line
after each of these print statements. Okay, so the
output is that the first two lines are the same,
they are giving us the address of the first
element in the array and the second two lines
are giving us the value. In fact, if we run
a loop like this from zero to index four,
then we can print address of the element
at index i as ampersand AI or a plus i
and we can print the value of if element as a AI
and Asterix a plus AI. Now, if we see the output
here, this is a fresh run a new run so the address
or locations will change. But if we see the
address printed in two lines for a zero is same
the value is same again for a one addresses same
four bytes I had off the previous address and the
value is as expected and we can go on like this.
Now one more thing even though just using
the variable name a returns us pointer to the
base address or the address of the first
element and we can equate the variable name
a against some pointer variable like this. We
cannot do something like a plus plus increment the
value of a this will give us compilation error. We
can do something like p plus plus once we assign
a to some pointer variable other pointer variable
but incrementing a itself would be invalid.
So this As far as how arrays are stored in memory
and how the addresses can be manipulated, and how
we can access the values using pointers, in the
next lessons in the coming lessons, we will talk
about character arrays. And we will talk about
passing arrays as function arguments. So thanks
for watching. In this lesson, we will be talking
about one more scenario in which the concept of
arrays and pointers go together. And this scenario
is when you pass an array as function argument,
let us see a code example where we pass array
as function argument and try to analyze it,
I will write a simple C program in which I will
write a function that will give me the sum of
all the elements in an integer array, this
function will take an integer array as argument,
this is one of the ways to pass an integer array,
an array in general as argument, this would be
the data type and this would be the name of the
array. And in the main method, we have declared
and initialized an array named a. Now, in the main
method, we will call this function sum of elements
and pass it the array as argument. And of course,
we need to write the body of this function, sum
of elements, I will declare two variables I and
another variable sum and initialize it to zero,
I will be used to run a loop. So, we will
iterate through all the elements in the
array that is passed as argument. But wait a
minute, we do not know the size of this array,
is there some way to know the size of the
array. One of the ways to find out the size
of the array and by the size of the array, we
mean the number of elements in the array here
is to use the function size off. So if we write
something like size of a here in the main method,
then this will give us the size of the array
in bytes. array has five integers and in a
typical compiler, and I know for sure that in this
compiler and integer is stored in four bytes, so
size of a will return 20. If we want to know the
number of elements in the array, then we can do
something like divide the size of the size and
bytes of the whole array by size of one integer.
So we will say size of a upon size of each integer
and by the size of a zero would give us the
number of elements in the array.
And I'll write this particular line
below this line the line where we are
calling the function sum of elements.
Now, what we can do is we could either pass
the size of the array as another argument.
So that would be cool. And then we can
run the loop starting zero till index size
minus one and we keep on adding each
element to this variable sum. And finally,
we return sum. And finally, we will write
a print statement something like this,
to print the sum of all the elements in the array,
let us now run this program and see what happens
the output on console is that the sum of elements
is equal to 15 five plus four plus three plus two
plus one is 15. So, this is all right. Now, what I
want to do is I want to modify this code a little
I do not want to pass the size as argument here,
I want to calculate the size of the array inside
this function. So, we will not be passing
this sizes argument here. So there will be
there will be just one argument the array. So
we have this array as argument the array and we
calculate the size here as total size of the array
in bytes upon the size of one integer in bytes.
Let us now run this program and see what
happens. Oops, this seems to be some problem,
because the sum of elements that we have as output
on console here is equal to one it should be 15.
And why is it so, explain this behavior,
I will write two more print statements,
what is the function sum of elements where I will
print the size of a and the size of a zero I will
be calling these two functions size off upon a and
upon a zero respectively. And we will write one
more print statements in the main method. It will
again be the same thing printing the size of a in
bytes and the size of a zero in bytes. Let us now
see the output in the method sum of elements size
of A is equal to four bytes. size of a zero is
equal to four bytes in the method main size of
phase equal to 20 bytes and the size of a zero
again is four bytes. To understand this concept,
why the size of a is four by In the method sum of
elements and it is equal to 20 bytes in the main
method, we need to dive deep into how compiler
interprets an array as function argument. Once
again I will draw this familiar memory diagram,
the memory assigned to an application or a program
is typically divided into these four parts, we
have talked about this in our previous lessons
for the execution of function calls, we use
stack section of the memory, this green rectangle
here is our stack. Now, when the program starts
executing, first the main method is invoked. So
some amount of memory from the stack is allocated
corresponding to the call of the main method
and this particular section or this particular
part is also called the stack frame of a method
all the local variables reside within this
stack frame. Now, here in main method, we have
two local variables one is the array and
another local variable is integer total.
So, around 20 bytes if integer is four bytes,
exactly 20 bytes, in fact, would be allocated
from this stack frame for the local variable a the
array and four bytes for total the variable total
and there would be some more information
in the stack frame. Now, when the program
execution reaches this particular line,
where we make a call to sum of elements,
then the execution of main is paused and another
stack frame is allocated to execute the function
sum of elements. We have talked about this
call stack growth and function execution
a number of times in our previous lessons, okay,
now, this is a local variable, this parameter is
a local variable to the function sum of elements
it is not this a in the main method, what happens
when we make a function call is that the value of
this particular local variable in the main method,
or we should rather say the value from
the variable in the calling function is
copied to the variable in the call function. So
ideally, we should have one more a local to the
function called sum of elements. and the value
of a should be copied into this parameter A.
So we would have another array named a, taking
20 bytes in the stack frame of some of elements,
and it would have the same value same
elements as the array in the calling function
main. But actually, this doesn't happen, when
compilers sees an array as function argument,
it does not copy the whole array, what it actually
does it, it just creates a pointer variable by the
same name, instead of creating the whole array,
it just creates a pointer to the data type of
the array. So in this case, it will be pointed to
integer and the compiler just copies the address
of the first element in the array of the calling
function. So, let's say the starting address
the address of the first element in this array,
that belongs to the main method is 200. So,
in sum of elements, all that happens is a pointer
to integer is created and the value in this
pointer to integer is 200. The compiler implicitly
converts this int a to something like in Star a,
that is this a here in this particular format is
not interpreted as an array, but it is interpreted
as pointer to integer. So whether you write int
space variable name following these brackets, or
you write something like in Star space a, they're
both the same. We have a term for this, instead
of copying the value of the variable, we are just
copying and storing the address of the variable.
So, we make a call by reference here, arrays
always are passed as a reference parameters.
And this makes a lot of sense, because arrays
can be really large inside so it does not make
much sense to create a new copy of the array each
time it is unnecessarily using a lot of memory.
So for arrays, there is no call by value
there is always a call by reference. And
that's why this size of a here would give us four
as output, because A is a pointer to integer here,
while here in the main method is an array. So this
format of passing array as function argument where
we put these braces to tell that this is an array
is actually interpreted something like this by the
compiler. You can put an asterisk sign here or you
can put an Asterix sign here. It's the same thing.
It makes more sense to write it like this.
So A is actually interpreted as a pointer to
integer. That's why when we pass array as function
argument, there is no way to know the number of
elements in the array. By using a trick like this,
we actually need to pass the size of the array.
So I'd rather move this size calculation
in the main method and pass the size.
And when we run this program, now, we get
the output as expected sum of elements is
15. We should always keep in mind that a
variable name which is used as an array
is different from a variable which is pointed
to integer. Even though the compiler gives us
some privileges, like we can use the name of the
array to get the pointer to the first element,
like in this function sum of elements, we could
say something like to pass the first element,
we should, we could have said ampersand
is zero, the address of the first element.
But if we just use a instead of using ampersand a
zero, then that is allowed if A is an array. But
if a is an array, we cannot do something like
incrementing or decrementing. It like pointer
variables. With pointer variables,
we can do couple of other stuffs.
And if we have a pointer to the starting
address of the array, we can pretty much use
it like a variable name for array because II II
is interpreted as value at address a plus i. So
we need to keep these differences and similarities
in mind, it's a little tricky. There is one more
thing because the array is passed by reference,
we can modify the elements of the array in the
call function, and it would refer reflect in
the calling function. So let's say instead of
calculating the sum total, we want to double
all the elements, each individual element in the
array. So our code will go something like this, I
want to say that AI is now twice API. And we will
not return an integer let's say the return type
is void. And in the main method, I'll clear all
this stuff. And what I'll do is I'll simply run
a loop to print all the elements in the array
Okay, let us now run this and see what happens.
Oops, I forgot to call the function double
I must make a call before I print the
elements Okay. Let us now run this.
If you see the elements in the array are modified
each element is twice its previous value,
because this is called by reference the same copy
of the array is modified using dereferencing.
So this was array as function arguments. An
important use case of array as function argument
is when we work with strings in C strings
in C are nothing but character arrays.
This concept really becomes important in the
context of character arrays, we will be talking
about it in the coming lessons. So thanks for
watching. In our lesson, so far, we have seen
how the concepts of arrays and pointers go
together. Now in this lesson, we are going
to talk about character arrays, how we can
work with character arrays using pointers.
When we talk about character arrays in C,
we basically want to talk about strings.
Strings are group or set of characters,
and real world data like names, phrases,
and sentences. All of these are strings to us.
So these are some of the examples of strings.
Character arrays become all the more important
because we use them to store strings, and then
perform a lot of operations on strings, like
modifying a string, copying a string concatenating
two strings or finding out properties of strings
like finding out the length of a string. To be
able to work with strings efficiently in C, there
are a couple of things that we need to understand.
The first thing that we need to understand
is how we store strings in character arrays.
To be able to store a string in a character
array. The first requirement is that
the character array should be large enough to
accommodate the string. And what is a large enough
character array. A large enough character array is
a character array of size greater than or equal to
number of characters in the string
plus one. So let's say if our string is
a name of four characters, like john, then
the size of the array should be greater than
or equal to five. Now the obvious question would
be why do we need space for one extra character?
Isn't it that if we layer, character array of size
four, we can store all the characters in john j
will go at the zero at index, four will go at the
one at index, H and n will go at second and third
index respectively. So I'm storing all the data,
isn't it? Let's try to understand it this way.
Let's say we have a character array of size eight.
Let's say this is a logical view of our array C,
and we want to store the string john, in this
particular array, we have indices from zero to
seven, and this is an array of size eight.
So we can store j at the zero at index o at
the one at index H, add to it index and n add
the three utter index. So we have stored all
the characters of the string john in this array.
But if you see we have not stored one information,
or we have not stored the information that this
particular character, n is the last character in
the string, so the string ends at index three. So
let's say if we pass this string to a function,
and that has to print the string john, or find out
the length of the string that we have stored in
this array, then how would the function know that
the string is only till index three, even though
we have not filled anything in these indices at
four or five, six and seven, there would be some
garbage value there. So either we pass this
extra information, or we do something else,
to store this information that this is the
end of the string in the character array.
This is the used part of the string. And this is
the unused part, we use a simple design at the end
of the string in the next position, we put a null
character, and null character has asked by value
zero. And we can put a null character at position
four in this example, something like this,
within single quotes, we put a forward slash
and number zero, this is null character. All
the functions for string manipulation in C, expect
that strings will be null terminated. So this is
a rule string in C has to be terminated by a null
character. And that's why we need one extra space
to store this null character. Let us try to see
some running code that will help us understand
this concept better. What I have done here is I
have taken a character array of size four, and
I have filled in the characters, but I have not
used any space to null terminated. And then I'm
using the printf function, this percentile, so it
tells that I want to print a string and then I'm
passing this array C. Let us run this program and
see what happens. As we can see, there are these
bunch of characters that are getting printed after
john, this is happening because we have broken
the assumption for the printf function that my
string that are a string will be null terminated.
So that's why this undefined behavior is coming.
If we change the size of the character array to
five and put a null termination, something like
this at fourth index, and then things will be
fine. Now even if we change the size of the array
to 20 printf function will print till it finds
a null character. So it only prints on the
first four characters in the array. And it's
not just the print function, there are a bunch
of functions, we have this library string dot h,
that gives us a bunch of function for string
manipulation. So all these functions assume
that the string will be null terminated. So this
is one contract that we have to follow. Let's
say we want to use one function str le n string
length. To find out this length of the string,
I'll print something like this, let's run this and
see as you can see, the output is length is equal
to four even though the array is of size 20. So
string length function also counts still it sees a
null character. In our program, instead of writing
these characters individually at this positions,
we could have used string literals string literals
are group of characters within double quotation
marks. So we could have written something like
this. And this would have initialized C as
the string and the null termination for a string
literal is implicit, it is always stored with a
null termination and memory. Remember, when we
declare and initialize a character array like
this, this has to happen in one line, we cannot
do something like we declare in one line and then
we go on and modify this in the next line this
will be invalid. We could also avoid writing
this size here, and this would have been fine.
In this case, the size of C will be five units,
five bytes where one byte stores one character.
So it would be just enough to store the string
john. So if we try to print the size in bytes of
C, using The size of function, then size in bytes
is five one character stored in one byte. So space
has been allocated for five characters, but the
length is four, because the null character does
not count in the length, if we write something
like c four is equal to this particular string
literal with four characters, this will give us
compilation error, because the compiler will force
this particular array to be of minimum size five,
there is one more syntax of initialization we can
put all these characters as a comma separated list
within these braces, but in this case,
the null termination will not be implicit,
we will have to do it explicitly. And the size
of the array has to be greater than or equal
to the number of characters here, so it should be
greater than or equal to five. Okay, so these are
some of the ways to initialize a character array.
The next thing that we need to understand is,
arrays and pointers are different types that are
used in similar manner. Now, what does it really
mean? Well, let's say we declare a character
array, see one of size six, and initialize it
with this string literal. And let's say this is
how it gets stored in the memory, or is stored
in one contiguous block of memory. So let's say
the first character is at address 201 character
is of size one bytes, so the next character will
be at address 201. And the next will be at 202,
and so on. Now c one is the variable name for this
whole array. Now what I'll do is, I'll declare a
variable, which is a pointer to character, let's
name this C two. So let's say we get this variable
c two somewhere in the memory, a pointer variable
in a typical architecture is stored in four bytes.
So this variable will also have some address,
let's say this variable is at address 400.
I'm just picking up these numbers for example
sake, now, what we can do is we can write a
statement like this C two is equal to c one.
Now even though c one is a character array is
a variable name for character array. And c two
is a variable which is pointed to character,
this particular expression is valid, just using
the name of the array actually returns the address
of the first element in the array. So what this
expression, what this statement will do is,
it will fill in the address 200 and C two. So C
two now points to the first element in the array.
Now, we can use this variable c two, which is a
character pointer, or just like C one to read and
write into the array. So if I write something like
print c two, I, let's say we want to print c Two,
one, then the output will be L. and we can even
modify the array. Let's say we want to modify
the character at zero at index two A. So the
string will be modified and will become this,
when we write C two I for any position I it is
nothing but as strict c two plus i. So C two is
the base address, C two plus, I will take you
to the address of the eighth element. So in this
case, let's say C two plus two will be 202. And
if we put this asterik operator, we are basically
dereferencing and finding out the value, so these
two syntaxes are alternate syntaxes. And even if
it is an array name, we can write on these two as
substitutes for each other. So this was all the
similarity in how we actually use them use arrays
and pointers to read and write. Let us now look at
the differences. We cannot modify an array with a
statement like this, C two equals c one is valid,
but c one equals c two is not valid, it does
not make sense, this will give you a compilation
error, we cannot even say C one is equal to c
one plus one, we cannot increment or decrement.
This video we'll see what we can do it for C two,
which is a pointer variable, we can say C two plus
plus so C two now points to the next element.
With this statement here, all that will happen
is C two will become 201. So instead of pointing
here, it's now pointing to this particular element
e to traverse an array, we run a loop and we
use a local variable let's say I and increment
it in the loop if we have a pointer variable,
we can just keep on incrementing the pointer
and we can traverse the list we can traverse the
array, we will keep doing this C two plus plus.
So we must understand where we have an array and
where we have a pointer and what we can do with
which one. Now, the next thing that we need to
understand is that arrays are always passed to
functions by reference or when we pass arrays
to functions, we only pass the base address
of the array in a pointer variable and we do not
pass a whole copy of the array. The compiler does
not let you do do that. And we have talked
about this in detail in our previous lesson.
Arrays as function arguments. Let us look through
some code and try to understand this better.
In my code, I have declared a character array of
size 20. And I have stored a string of length five
in this character array. The null termination
is implicit if we are using string literal.
Now I want to print this string, but I do
not want to use the library function print F,
I want to write my own function print, I want to
pass this array to the function. And this function
should print the string part in a character
array. The argument to the function we have
talked about this earlier can be something like
this to say that we are receiving an array here,
but the compiler actually interprets this as
this. So the compiler forces that only the address
of the character array or the address of any array
be received as argument to the function, because
arrays are large in size, so it is inefficient to
create a copy of the same array for each function.
Okay, so let's write the logic now. Now, this
print function does not have any idea that this
particular array is of size 20, it only knows
the base address. So what we can do is we can
have a variable I initialize it to zero and we can
say something like this, while ci is not equal to
null character, we can print the character ci,
and then we will increment i. And when we find
a null character, we can come out of this loop
and print an end of line. Once again, this print
function does not know that this character arrays
of size 20, it only knows the base address.
And that's why in the printf function,
when we were not null terminating an array, we
were printing all the garbage value even after the
array was finished. Because until we get a null
character, we do not know where to stop, and we
keep on going into unwanted memory locations.
Now this code should work. Yes, this is fine.
In my code, here, I'm using percent and see
here to say that we want to print character,
and see if we can also write as strict c plus II
as substitute for ci. And that will also mean the
same. Sometimes you'll see this kind of syntax. As
we talked earlier, both of these syntax as trixi
plus imci are valid, they are the same, there is
one more thing in our code that we may do, we will
not choose to have this particular variable i,
we could simply say that while Asterix c is not
equal to null, print, Asterix C and then increment
c itself. And this code will also work on why this
code will work. I leave it as an exercise for you
to think in the coming lessons, we will implement
more functions for string manipulation. This is it
for now. Thanks for watching. In part one of our
lesson on character arrays and pointers, we saw
how we can store strings in character arrays. And
we also saw how we can work with character arrays
using pointers in some of the basic scenarios.
Whenever we are working with pointers, it's
really important that we visualize how things are
happening in the memory. So, the first thing that
we will do in this lesson is we will simulate the
program that we had written in the previous
lesson to print the characters of a string
and see what goes where in the memory. And we will
also look into the concept of string constants
and constant pointers. So, this is where
we had left in our previous lesson,
we have written a function Print to print the
characters in a string in the main method,
we have a character array of size 20, but we
have stored a string of length five in it,
we have used a string literal, so null termination
is implicit, we have talked about this earlier.
So, let us step through this code and see how it
is working. Once again I have drawn this familiar
diagram the memory that is allocated for execution
of a program is typically divided into these
four parts these four sections on one part of the
memory stores the instructions in the program,
we call that the code segment or the text
segment, one part one section stores the
global variables and stack is where all the
information regarding function call execution and
all the local variables go whenever we are writing
a program whenever we are executing a program we
should always visualize what variable goes where
or what data goes where and what is the scope of
that variable or data okay. So, let us run through
this code and see what is happening in the memory.
When this program will start executing first
the main method, main function will be invoked
whenever a function is called some amount
of memory from the stack is allocated for
the execution. Attack function, it's called the
stack frame of that function. So, let us say,
this stack frame from address 100 250 is
allocated for the main function stack is
one contiguous block of memory. So let us say in
the stack the memory increases from bottom to top,
all the local variables of function go into the
stack frame of the function. So, when we declare a
character array, or 20 bytes from the stack frame
will be allocated for this particular character
array. Let's say they're allocated from address
100 220. Each character is stored in one byte,
so we need 20 bytes for character array of size
20. Apart from local variables, there may be
some more information and stack frame. So that's
why we have some more space. And now the control
of the program goes to the statement print
see, as soon as we make a call to another
function from a function, the execution of that
particular function is paused at that particular
line and the machine goes on to execute the
called function, the call function is allocated
stack frame on top of the calling function. So
print will be allocated a stack frame on top of
main function, whatever function is at the top
of the stack and at any point is executing main
will wait for this function to finish let's say
this particular stack frame is from 150 to 170.
Main is paused and print is executing right now.
Now print will also have a local variable C,
but this will be a pointer variable.
A pointer variable takes four bytes of
memory in a typical architecture. So this will be
taking four bytes. So let's say starting address
a 154. In this stack frame, we have four bytes
for this particular character pointer. So this C
in main is actually not the same C in print,
the C in main and the C in print are different.
They have different scopes, or we could have
named this particular variable a or PTR or
whatever. But all that happens when we make this
particular called to print and pass this see here
is that the address 100 which is the base address
of the array is passed to the print function and
the print function keeps it stores it in a
pointer variable. Sometimes it may confuse
us when we are using the same local variable
name in the calling function and the same
argument name in the called function. But we
must always understand that they are different.
Okay to run through this code further. I'll clear
some space here. Now. I'll draw this array c
outside the stack here we have an array of
size 20. But we are only showing the first
six positions in the array from address 100 205.
And that's why it is extending towards the right.
The sixth character is a null character and the
first five characters are the characters of word
hello. Now we have this another guy which is
C of print, which is a character pointer at
address 154 that stores address 100 so it points
to the first element of the array. Now let's
come back to our program execution. Let's say we
are here initially, I'll mark the statement that
is executing by this green arrow or Let's
name these two guys this guy see but this guy
is an array, local domain and this is also c
but it is a character pointer local to print.
Okay, so now here what we're saying is, while
Asterix c is not equal to the null character,
when we put this asterik operator in front of a
pointer variable, we are looking at the value at
that particular address. So at this stage, when
C is pointing to the base address as Trixie is H,
so this condition is not true, we will go to
this line printf that will simply print Asterix C
which is h let's write down the output here. So we
have printed h so far, and then we say c++. If we
understand pointer arithmetic from our previous
lessons incrementing a pointer by one unit
increments the address by size of the data
type that the pointer points to see here is a
pointer to character data type and character data
type is one byte. So C plus one, c++ is saying
C is equal to C plus one. So C now becomes 101. So
now c points to the second character in the array.
And once again we come to verifying this condition
in the while loop as Trixie Is he here it's not
null. Now once again we will go inside the loop
and print E and we will keep on going like this
builder address in this pointer variable
reaches 105. Now here, the value at this
particular addresses null character so the
loop Will not execute, or we will come to
this statement to print and end offline and
the execution of print function will finish.
So this particular stack frame for print will
be cleared from the stack will be de allocated.
And now main will resume and finished. So with
pointers, we should always know what's going where
in the memory. Okay, so let us now modify this
particular code to learn some more concepts.
Or what I'm going to do in my code is, instead
of creating a character array of size 20,
I'll create a character pointer named C and
equated against a string literal in a statement
like this. And if you run this program on the
output will be the same, what really happens is
if you use the string literal initializations
to statement of an array something like this,
and then the string get stored in the space
that is allocated to the array. So in this case,
it will go into the stack in this character array
of size 20. But if you use the string literal
elsewhere in a statement like this, or maybe when
we do something like passing a string literal
to a function, then in these cases, the string
gets stored as a constant during the compile time,
most probably it will be stored in the
text segment of the application memory, and
it cannot be modified. So if you write a
statement like this, let's say you want to
change the first character of this constant
string to a or running this program will
give you an error will cause a crash. Okay,
coming back to having a character array. Now,
if we have a character array, and we are passing
on the address of the array to a function,
that function receives it in a character
pointer. Now, using this pointer, we can modify
the data in this particular array. So if I say
something like this, we first change the first
character to a and then we are printing
the characters. And then as you can see,
it is possible to do so. Now sometimes we may want
a function and just to read a string and not write
anything. to force this kind of behavior, we can
change our argument to const character pointer.
Now if we run this code, this code will give us
compilation error, or we can read whatever is
there in the array that is passed. But we cannot
write to any of the positions, and this code
will work fine. pointers are really tricky,
and even the most experienced programmers
write buggy code when they're using pointers,
I recommend that you get your hands dirty by
writing some code yourself. That's the best way to
learn. So this is it for this lesson. Thanks for
watching. In this lesson, we are going to talk
about pointers and multi dimensional arrays.
As we have seen in our previous lessons, the
concepts of pointers and arrays go together. We
have already talked about pointers in context of
one dimensional arrays, how we can work with one
dimensional arrays using pointers. Now let's
see how we can work with a two dimensional
array or a three dimensional array, or a multi
dimensional array in general, using pointers.
To understand this concept, once again, we first
need to understand how multi dimensional arrays
are organized in computer's memory. Let's first go
back to the organization of one dimensional arrays
in memory. When we declare a one dimensional array
something like this, let's say we are declaring
an integer array A of five elements, then
basically what we are doing is we are creating
five different integer variables that we can name
a zero, a one, a two, a three and a four as one
contiguous block of memory. What I'm showing here
is a section of computer's memory, or a let's say
is stored in this section of memory, and the
starting address of A is 200. As we know each
byte in a computer's memory has an address. And if
we assume that an integer is stored in four bytes,
which is what it takes, in a typical compiler,
then the block of four bytes starting address 200
will be a zero, as I'm showing here, block of four
bytes starting address 204 will be a one. Next
block of code byte starting address 208 will be
a two and so on. I'll fill in some values here.
We had seen this earlier also in our previous
lessons. If we write a statement like this,
then this is all right. If I just use the variable
name a then name of the array in an expression
basically returns a pointer to the first
element of the array, because this is an
array of integers. So each element will be an
integer Hence a returns a pointer to integer.
Once I have written a statement like int Asterix
p equal a, I can use pointer arithmetic and
dereferencing to access all the elements in
the array, if I would just try to print the
address stored in P and I'm not using full
printf statement here, my output will be 200
if I would simply try to dereference
p, then output will be two if I would
try to print something like Asterix
p plus two, then output will be six
because we have an integer pointer adding one
will take us to the address of the next integer
which will be four bytes ahead adding to will take
us to the address of next to next which will be
eight bytes ahead if we would be printing p plus
two it will be 208. And if we would dereference
and we would print Asterix p plus two then it
will be value six, we have already discussed
pointer arithmetic in our previous lessons. Now
language gives us this flexibility that we can use
the name of the array just like a pointer
for all the dereferencing. So instead of
doing all of this printing with P if we will do
all of this with a it will still be the same.
In fact Asterix a plus i is same as AI these are
alternate syntax and a plus i is same as ampersand
AI both will give us the address of the ayat
element in the array. Please remember that even
though we can use the name of the array just like
pointer for all this dereferencing and arithmetic,
it's not seen as a pointer variable. So
we can do something like p equal a like
what we have done here. So this is all right.
But we cannot do the other way we cannot say
equal p this will give you a compilation error.
So this is pretty much how we would use pointers
with one dimensional arrays. Let's now say
we want to create a two dimensional array,
I will declare a two dimensional array
of integers named t something like this.
Now, what we are doing here is we are creating
array of array, we are creating two one
dimensional arrays of three elements each this
time be zero and B one are both one dimensional
arrays of three integers each. a one dimensional
array of three integers would be 12 bytes, if each
integer is four bytes in size. So if I have to
show this in memory, the first block of 12 bytes
starting address 400 will be B zero. And the next
block of 12 bytes starting address 412 will be b1.
As we had said name of the array returns a pointer
to the first element in the array. This time each
element is not an integer, each element is a one
dimensional array of three integers. So if I would
write a statement like this int Asterix p equals
p, then this will give me a compilation error,
because b will return a pointer to a 1d array of
three integers and not just a pointer to integer,
the type of a pointer matters not when you have to
read the address. It matters when you dereference
or when you perform pointer arithmetic. It's
really important that we understand this we can
define a pointer to a 1d array of three integers
like this. And now if I equate this with B,
this is all right. equate B with B this time if
I would print just p which is same as printing
address of B zero, this will be 400 if I
will print Asterix P which will be same as
B zero, then B zero this time is variable name
for a one dimensional array of three integers.
So just using the name B zero will return us a
pointer to the first in teaser in B zero which
will be accessed as p 00. So I'm putting
this ampersand sign here in front of P 00.
First integer in B zero will be this block
of four bytes. Its address once again is 400.
Okay, now I have also created three blocks of
four bytes each in both v zero and v one and
also filled in some values. Now I'm going to
write some print statements and I want you
to guess the output. What will be the output
if I'll try to print B plus one I will write
the address of each block of four bytes
in the 2d array the address of a block
is the address of the first byte in the block.
Okay, so what will be the value of B plus one
B this time is returning us a pointer to
one dimensional array of three integers.
So, if I would do a pointer arithmetic like adding
plus one, we are moving to the next one the array
of three integers. So, we will be moving to
address 400 plus size of one dimensional array
of three integers in bytes. So, output will be 412
which makes sense because p plus one is same as
ampersand B one or address of B one and address
of B one is 412 okay now, what if I print Asterix
B plus one when we are putting an Asterix signs
when we are trying to dereference This is when the
type of pointer becomes important B is a pointer
to one dimensional array of three integers. So,
B plus one is also a pointer to one dimensional
array of three integers and when we will
dereference we will get this whole one dimensional
array of three integers starting address 412
Asterix B plus one is same as B one. So, we will
get b one now printing B one means using the
name of this one dimensional array B one which
should return us the pointer to the first
integer in B one. So, astrick b plus one is
basically pointer to this integer at address 412.
Once again this output will be 412 all these
expressions Asterix p plus one or B one or
ampersand v one, zero are returning us pointer
to integer okay now you need to get up because
I'm going to give you some tough ones to decode
what will be the output if I will print Asterix
B plus one plus two, take some time and think
about it. Asterix B plus one as we saw above,
will return an integer pointer to first integer
and B one to the integer at address 412. Adding
to here is performing pointer arithmetic because
Asterix p plus one is a pointer to integer
storing this address 412 adding to is basically
going to the address of next to next integer,
which will mean skipping eight bytes and and going
to reference in teacher at address 420 as strict B
plus one in this expression can be written as b
one simply be one because they are substitutes
for each other their alternate syntax. So this
is same as B one plus two. And once again,
these expressions are returning pointer to
integer they are returning pointer to this element
B one two. That's why we can also say ampersand
B one two, all these three once again are seen.
Let's do one more print. If you can get this one
right, I can say that you're good working with two
dimensional arrays using pointers what will be the
output for this expression as trick of Asterix,
Asterix of Asterix B plus one what will be the
output for this expression? Think about it,
whenever you encounter an expression with pointer
arithmetic and dereferencing then you must go step
by step here B is returning us a pointer to one
dimensional array of size three one dimensional
array of three integers and dereferencing it will
give us the one dimensional array. So asterik B
as we know will give us B zero asteroid B is
same as B zero. Now B zero in my expression,
because B's row is named for a one dimensional
array returns me a pointer to the first integer
in the one dimensional array. So b zero returns a
pointer to integer we will get appointed to this
integer at address 400. Now, what will happen if
you will add one to an integer pointer, it will
take you four bytes ahead to the next integer it
will return you a pointer to the next integer. So
we will get a pointer to this integer at address
404 astrick b plus one is basically ampersand b
01. And with this final dereferencing we can get
rid of this ampersand. So the overall expression
will be p 01 which is three for a two
dimensional array b i j where b is named
for my two dimensional array and i and j are
some indices can be written as Asterix of B i
plus j and once again p AI can be
written as as strict SOF B plus i.
So these three expressions are same. I would
recommend trying all of this in real code.
So far this discussion has been about working
with two dimensional arrays using pointers. We
will stop here for this lesson. In another lesson
we will play with some real code And we will also
discuss how we can work with an array of further
higher dimension like a three dimensional array.
We will also discuss passing of arrays
to functions through pointers. This is
it for this lesson. Thanks for watching. In
our previous lesson, we saw how we can work
with two dimensional arrays using pointers.
Now in this lesson, we will see how we can
work with arrays of further higher dimensions
like three dimensional arrays using pointers.
We will also see how we can pass multi dimensional
arrays as arguments to functions because that's
one scenario where pointers once again will come
into picture. I will start with a quick recap of
what we have discussed in our previous lesson.
Whenever we create a multi dimensional array,
and let's pick up the example of two dimensional
array that we had created in our previous lesson,
we must think of the multi dimensional array as an
array of arrays. Array basically, is a collection
of similar things of similar objects. So a multi
dimensional array is basically a collection of
arrays. This array B here is a collection of one
dimensional arrays of three elements each, we have
to one dimensional arrays of three elements each,
what I have tried to show in this figure is how
array B will be organized in memory, I have
assumed that the starting address of the array is
400. Each cell storing and teacher here is a block
of four bytes. As we know each byte in computer's
memory has an address, I'm not drawing all the
bytes partition for all the bytes, I'm trying
blocks of four bytes each. And that's why I'm
writing only the starting address of each block,
you can imagine a block of four bytes something
like this, the starting address is 400. Let's say
each partition here is one byte. So the next byte
has address 401 and the next one has address 402.
And the next one has address 403. Overall, this
first block of 12 bytes, that will that contains
these three integers two, three, and six that I'm
showing in yellow here is my first one dimensional
array that I can call B zero. And this next block
of 12 bytes is my second one dimensional array of
three integers that I can call B one. So we have
two one dimensional arrays in our collection,
we have two collections of three integers each
in our collection, and everything is organized
in one contiguous block of memory. Now let's look
at this B zero is from byte address 400 till 411
we have three integers and we have four bytes
for each integer. The first integer that we can
access as element at zero at index of B zero is
taking four bytes starting address 400 the next
integer that can be accessed as p 011 element
of B zero will take next four bytes starting 404
and the next one will be v 02 element at index
two of P zero. And similarly we will have four
bytes for zeroeth element of v one four bytes for
one element and four bytes four element at index
two of B one as we had seen in our previous
lesson when we just use the array name,
then it returns us a pointer to the first element
of the array. Here B is a two dimensional array
it is an array of one dimensional arrays of size
three. So b will basically return us a pointer to
one dimensional array of three elements pointer
to one dimensional array of three integers. In
this statement, I have declared a variable which
is pointer to one dimensional array of three
integers and the name of the variable is be a
statement like this is all right, a statement like
this will not be alright because b will not return
a pointer to integer B will return a pointer to
one dimensional array of three integers. Now
I will write three print statements that I had
also written in our previous lesson. I'm not
writing the complete syntax for printf. Okay,
so once again you need to tell me what will be the
output if we would print these three expressions
we have p Asterix B and B zero. Well for all
these three, output will be 400. here when we
say B just using the array name B will return us
a pointer to the first one dimensional array in B
the type of a pointer variable is relevant
only when we are trying to dereference or
perform pointer arithmetic. But if we will
just try to print the address stored in the
pointer variable it will be the starting address
address of the first byte of a block of memory.
So if we have a pointer to this one dimensional
array that is storing two, three Six,
then it's addresses 400. Now when we did an
Asterix B, which is same as B zero, we data
friends and now we have got the complete
one dimensional array B zero. Now if I use
B zero because b zero is a one dimensional array,
we will get a pointer to the first integer in
B zero, so we will get a pointer to bs 00 in
this block of four bytes starting address 400.
Once again if we would just print the address,
then the starting address of this block is 400.
That's why the output here is 400. Even if I would
print ampersand bs 00, the output will be 400 B
and Asterix B are both returning us pointers, the
difference is that B is returning a pointer to a
one dimensional array of three integers while
Asterix B is returning a pointer to an integer,
when we are just printing the address both
these objects the complete one dimensional
array B zero and the first element in B zero have
the same starting address. So the same starting
address will be printed the type of pointer
plays a role when you try to dereference or
when you try to perform pointer arithmetic.
We had also seen in our previous lesson that
B IJ can be written as Asterix of B i plus j if b
II for some value of i is a one dimensional array,
then b i will give us an integer pointer will
return us an integer pointer to the first integer
in bi then adding j is basically performing
pointer arithmetic and getting a pointer to
integer at index j in one dimensional array bi
and then finally this dereferencing is getting
the value of that integer. Once again be
I can be written as Asterix B plus i B
is a pointer to one dimensional array of three
integers. So b plus I will also return a pointer
to one dimensional array of three integers and
T referencing this particular dereferencing will
give us the one dimensional array and the name
of one dimensional array returns us a pointer to
the first element in the array. So this once again
will be pointer to integer. By now if you clearly
understand how all the pointer arithmetic and
dereferencing is happening in these expressions,
then it's not very difficult to understand how
things will be for say a three dimensional array.
Now let's say we have created a three dimensional
array named C we have an array of three cross two
cross two or three dimensional array is basically
an array or collection of two dimensional arrays.
So if I have to show C in memory,
I will show it something like this,
I have assumed that the starting address of C is
byte addressed 800 the first 16 bytes starting
address 800 is my first two dimensional array,
I am assuming that each integer will take four
bytes. So all these cells in yellow are
part of the first two dimensional array.
The next block of 16 bytes starting address
816 is C one and the next block of 16 bytes
starting a 32 is C two, we can further break down
the two dimensional arrays into one dimensional
arrays. The first two integers in c zero are
part of the first one dimensional array c 00.
And seven and nine are part of C 01. The first
integer in C 00 can be accessed as C 000. And we
can go on like this. Okay, once again, we'll play
the same game, I will write some print statements
and you need to guess the output. This time just
using the array name C will give us a pointer to
a two dimensional array of integers of size two
cross two. So we can write a statement like this
I have declared a pointer to a two dimensional
array of integers of size to cross to hear the
name of the point that is B if I would just print
p or C here and I'm not writing the complete
printf statement once again my output will be 800.
Now if I will perform a dereferencing and try to
print Asterix C then this will be seen as c
zero and c zero is a two dimensional array.
So we will get a pointer to the first element
in c zero. All these expressions are returning
us a pointer to one dimensional array of integers
of size two and the address printed will be
800. Remember C is of type pointer to 2d array
of two cross two and Dear friends in ones is
giving us point at a one dimensional array
of two integers, C is returning us pointer to
two dimensional array of integers c itself is an
array, there is difference between the two types
okay for c c ij k where i j and k are some
indices can be written as Asterix off c ij plus
K and now once again we can write C ij
as Asterix of C i plus j and the overall
expression will look something like this and we
can go ahead and write C i as Asterix of C plus i
if you are able to understand how
I have derived these expressions,
if you are able to understand all the pointer
arithmetic and dereferencing in these expressions,
then you are good working with multi
dimensional arrays using pointers.
I want a quick answer for this one what
will be the output for this print statement?
Well c 01 means we are going to this one
dimensional array that has these two elements
seven and nine. And when we are using the our
namc Is it a one we are getting a pointer to first
integer in this one dimensional array pointer
to this integer seven, adding one we are doing
pointer arithmetic to an integer pointer So, we
will go to nine and data referencing will give us
integer nine. In fact, this expression is same as
C of 011. Now, what will be the output for this
print statement aspects of C one plus one c one
will return us a pointer to one dimensional array,
the first one dimensional array in C one,
this block containing integers three and four,
adding one is performing pointer arithmetic
and going to the next one dimensional array,
it's going to this one dimensional array
containing six and one. And now dereferencing
is basically getting the one dimensional array
from the pointer. And if you just use the name
of the one dimensional array, you get a pointer
to the first element in one dimensional array.
So we will get a pointer to this
integer six, output will be 824.
This block of four bytes storing address
storing integer three is 816. Next would be
next will be a 20 and next will be a 24 we can
try out these expressions in a real program.
I'm writing this simple C program I have
created this three dimensional array see
the data filled in is same as we were showing
in the example. In the first printf statement
I'm writing I'm trying to print c astrak, c c zero
and ampersand c 00. All of these are pointers. And
if I will just use person D address would be
printed. When I'm running this code as you can see
the output for all these four expressions is same.
Any guesses for what will be the output for this
printf statement, this expression is nothing but
c 001. The output for first printf is different
because this is a different run of the program and
in each run, the assigned address will change. But
whatever the address is, it will be seen for these
four expressions, I would recommend trying out all
the different expressions that we were decoding
earlier in a real program like this. Okay, the
next thing that I want to talk about is passing
multi dimensional arrays has function arguments.
I'm going to declare a function and
let's name this function f u n c. And
I want this function to accept a three dimensional
array as argument. So what do I do? If I wanted
a one dimensional array as argument I could have
given something like this. But as we had discussed
in one of our previous lessons, this syntax is
only a syntactical sugar it is interpreted like
this by the compiler. A fresh copy of array is
not created for a function call, only a reference
to it in the form of a pointer is created. So
now if in the main function, I have an array
of one dimensional array like this, and let's
say the return type of this function is void,
I can make a function called passing a like
this and this will be fine. Now let's say
we declare a two dimensional array of two cross
three. And now we want this function to receive
to take a two dimensional array as argument. Now
as we discussed, he will Her return has pointed
to in teacher but B will return us a pointer to
array of three integers one dimensional array of
three integers for this particular definition
of p. So, for the function to take this array
p as argument definition should be something
like this argument should be something like this,
either we can write this or we can write
something like this, only the first dimension
can be left empty the other dimension has to
be specified. And now I can pass B, there is
something interesting here, if I would declare
a two dimensional array something like this,
let's declare a two dimensional array x have to
cross for now, I cannot pass x to the function,
because x will return pointer to one
dimensional array of foreign teachers,
while this function is supposed to receive
one dimensional array of three integers,
if x is defined something like this of dimension
five cross three, then passing x is fine.
Now, if we want to pass this three dimensional
array, then once again we need to see what pointer
types he will return. So, C will basically return
a pointer to two dimensional array of two cross
two. So, we can either use a syntax like this
or something like this and then we can pass c.
So, this is how things will be for any multi
dimensional array, except the first dimension
all other dimensions will be enforced. One
common mistake that people do is for a two
dimensional array, they try to use pointer to
pointer something like this. And for a three
dimensional array, they try to use something like
this, which just won't work. So, this is pretty
much what we wanted to talk about pointers and
multi dimensional arrays. Thanks for watching.
Memory is one important and crucial resource
on our machine. And it is always good to know
the architecture of memory, the way operating
system manages memory and the way a memory is
accessible to us as programmers. In this lesson,
we will discuss the concept of dynamic memory
and we will see how to work with dynamic memory
using C or c++ the memory that is assigned
to a program or application in a typical
architecture can be divided into four segments,
one segment of the memory is assigned to store
the instructions that needs to be executed.
Another section stores all the static or global
variables the variables that are not declared
inside a function and that have the whole lifetime
of an application they are accessible anywhere
during the whole lifecycle of the application as
long as the application is running, one section of
the memory is used to store all the information
of function calls and all the local variables
and we have also talked about stack in our lesson
on call by reference local variables are declared
inside a function and the live only
till the time the function is executing
the amount of memory set aside for these
three segments the text segment the global
variable segment and the stack does not grow
while the application is running. We will
come back to why we use this fourth segment
heap in a while, let us first understand how
these three segments of the memory are used. When
a program executes, I have a simple C program here
we have a function square that gives me the
square of a number we have another function
square of sum that is given two arguments x and
why and it returns us the square of x plus y and
in the main method, I'm just calling this function
square of some passing it two arguments A and B.
Let us now see what happens in the memory when
this program executes. Let us say this rectangle
in green here is memory reserved as stack and
this rectangle in Orange is the memory reserved as
statical global variables section when the program
starts executing first the main method is invoked
when the main method is invoked some amount of
memory from the stack is allocated for execution
of main and this total is a global variable. So it
should sit in this section. The amount of memory
allocated on stack for execution of main can also
be called the stack frame for the method main all
the local variables arguments and the information
where this function should should return back to
all this information is stored within this stack
frame. The size of the stack frame for a method
is calculated when the program is compiling.
Now, when main calls square of some method,
that's right shortcut s four s four squared off
some, then a stack frame is allocated for the
call to square of some all these local variables
x y Zed will set in this particular stack frame.
Now, sum of square calls square, let's
again put a shortcut here for square.
So, another stack frame for Squire and
it will have its own local variables
at any time during the execution of the program,
the function at the top of the stack is executing
and rest are kind of paused waiting for the
function above to return something and then it
will resume execution I have drawn this play and
pause button here in case you do not understand
Okay, so, this total is a global variable
it sits here in this section global variable
because it is not declared and declared inside
a function, we can access it anywhere. And then
we go to this particular statement where we call
square of sum and square of some calling square.
So right now, this is our call stack. This program
may not be the best way to implement this logic,
I have written this program this way
so that I can have some nested methods
calling each other let's say right now, we are
at this particular statement we are executing
executing this statement. So, at this stage
calls a call stack will have these three methods.
Now, when this method finishes, we will
return back to this particular statement.
As soon as Squire function will return, it will
be cleared from the stack memory and now some
square of some function will resume. Once again
when square of some finishes, the control will
come back to this particular line to line total is
equal to square of sum and main will resume again.
Now main we'll call printf. So once again
printf will go to the top of the stack
printf will finish and the control will come
back again to main and now main will finish
and when main finishes program will also finish.
So in the end, our global variables will also get
cleared, there was no need in this program. To
keep this variable total as global, we should
assign a variable as global only if it is needed
at multiple places in multiple functions, and it
is needed for the whole lifetime of the program.
Otherwise, it's a waste of memory to keep it
keep a variable for the whole lifetime of program
execution. We had kept one global variable in this
program just to understand the cost concepts.
Here, I must point out one more thing,
when our program starts our operating system
allocates some amount of reserved space, let's say
always allocates one MB of space as stack,
but the actual allocation of the stack frame
and the actual allocation of the local variables
happens from this stack during runtime. And if
our call stack grows beyond the reserved memory
for the stack, like for example, if a method
a calls b b call C and we go on calling and we
exhaust the whole space reserved for the stack,
then this is called Stack Overflow and
in this case, our program will crash.
One common case of Stack Overflow is when
you write a bad recursion and your program
goes infinitely into recursion. So, as we can see,
there are some limitations of stack the memory
set aside for stack does not grow during runtime
application cannot request more memory for stack.
So if it is one MB then if the allocation of
variables and functions in stack exceeds one MB
our program will crash for the allocation and de
allocation of memory onto the stack happens by a
set rule when a function is called it is pushed
onto the stack on top of the stack, when it
finishes it is popped or removed from the stack
it is not possible to manipulate the scope of a
variable if it is on the stack. Another limitation
is that if we need to declare a large data type
like an array as local variable then we need to
know the size of the array at compile time only.
If we have a scenario like we want to decide how
large the array will be based on some parameter
during runtime, then it is a problem that stack
for all these requirements like allocating large
chunks of memory or keeping variable in the
memory till the time we want. We have heap
like stack applications he is not fixed. Its size
can vary during the lifetime of the application.
And there is no set rule for allocation and
de allocation of memory. A program can totally
control how much memory to use from the heap
till what time to keep the data in the memory
during the applications lifetime and he can
grow as long as you do not run out of memory
on the system itself. That is a dangerous
thing also and we need to be really careful
about using heap For this reason, we also
sometimes call heap, free pool of memory or free
store of memory, we can get as much as we want
from the heap. How heap is implemented by the
operating system Language Runtime or the compiler
is something which can vary which is a thing of
computer architecture. But an abstracted way
of looking at the heap as a programmer is that
this is one large free pool of memory available
to us that we can use flexibly as per our need.
heap is also called dynamic memory and using the
heap is referred to as dynamic memory allocation.
And let us now see how to use the heap in our C
or c++ program. I will clear this code in the left
and I will draw one more rectangular block
here for our heap. There is one more thing
that I must point out before moving forward. He
is also one data structure. And if you do not
know about this data structure heap yet, you will
learn about it in your data structure course. But
this nomenclature here has nothing to do with
the heap data structure. The term heap here is
being used only for the large free pool of memory.
heap data structure does not come anywhere in this
context. This term often confuses a lot
of people when they know about heap data
structure. Stack is also one data structure but
the stack segment of the memory is actually an
implementation of stack data structure. But heap
is not an implementation of heap data structure.
To use dynamic memory in C, we need to know about
four functions malloc calloc, realloc and free to
use dynamic memory in c++ we need to know about
two operators new and delete. These four functions
can also be used in c++ because c++ has backward
compatibility, it is only a superset of C, but
c++ programmers mostly use these two operators,
new and delete, we will see some code examples
and try to understand how things happen. When
dynamic memory is used, let us first pick up
some code example in C, let us write a C program.
I'll clean up some of this stuff in the right
one MB first tag this was just an assumption. In
reality the size of the stack will be decided by
the operating system and the compiler, it is a
thing of architecture. Coming back to the code.
If we declare a variable like this, then this
variable is a local variable it goes on the stack
memory for this particular variable a will
be allocated from the stack frame of the main
method. Let us say we want to store an integer on
the heap to reserve or get some space allocated
on the heap, we need to call the malloc function
something like this, the malloc function asks for
how much memory to allocate on the heap in bytes,
when we say malloc and passes pass as argument
size of integer then we are saying that hey give
me a block of memory which is four bytes four
bytes is the typical size of an integer. So one
block of four bytes will be reserved or allocated
on the heap and malloc will return a pointer to
the starting address of this block and malloc
returns a void pointer. Let us say the starting
address of this block of four bytes is 200.
So malloc will return us the address 200. Now
we have a pointer to integer p, which is a local
variable to main. So this will be this will be
allocated in the stack frame of the main method.
We have done a typecasting here because malloc
returns pointer to wide, sorry, void pointer, and
p is an integer pointer. Now p stores the address
of this block of memory which is 200. So we have
got some block of memory on the heap, which we
want to use to store an integer. Right now we
do not know what's there in this particular block
of memory. If we want to fill in something here,
we need to dereference this location using the
pointer P and then put in some value. In fact,
the only way to use memory on heap is through
reference. All the malloc function does is
look for some free space in the heap book set or
reserved set for you and give back the pointer and
the only way you can access this particular block
by keeping a pointer variable which will be local
to function. Now, let us write something like
this, after writing 10 in this particular block,
I will go ahead and make one more call to malloc.
When I make one more call to malloc, one more
block of four bytes is allocated on the heap. And
let us say the addresses 400 for this block. Now,
the address that is returned by the second call to
malloc and restore this address in the variable p.
So, what happens is that P is now pointing to
the address 400. The next line writes 20. at
this address, we allocated one more block and
we modified that recipe to point to this block,
the previous block will still set in the heap.
This memory we're still consuming, it will not
be cleared off automatically. At any point in
our program, if we are done using some particular
block of memory which is dynamically allocated
unique using malloc. We also need to clear it
because it is unnecessary consumption of memory
which is an important resource. So, what we should
have done here is that once we were done using
this particular block of memory at 200, we should
have made a call to the function free any memory
which is allocated using malloc is cleared off
by calling free and to free we pass the pointer
to the starting address of the memory block.
So, now with this code, this first block of
memory will first be cleared and then we will
be pointing to another memory address. It is the
responsibility of the programmer to clear anything
on the heap if he has allocated it
and does not need it any further.
So if you see in terms of the scope of the
variable, anything allocated on the heap
is not automatically D allocated when the function
completes like on the stack, and it does not live,
it does not need to live for the whole lifetime
of the application like a global variable,
we can control when to free anything on the
heap when to deallocate anything on the heap.
If we wanted to store an array on the heap, like
let's say we wanted to store an integer array,
then all we do is make a call to the malloc asking
for one block of memory equal to the total size of
the array in bytes. So, if we want an integer
array of 20 elements, then we will make a call
to malloc asking 20 into size of int which will
be for number of bytes. So what will happen now
is that one big contiguous block of memory for
20 integers will be allocated on the heap and
we will get the starting address of this block.
So we kind of get the base address of the array,
the speed will point here to the base address of
this block. And then in our code we can use this
20 integers as P zero p one, p two and so on.
As we know, P zero is same as saying value at
address P and P one is same as saying value
at address p plus one, this is what it means.
One more thing, if malloc is not able to find any
free block of memory is not able to allocate some
memory on the heap, it returns null. So for
error handling, we need to know this. And we
need to write our code appropriately malloc and
free the use of malloc and free a C style code.
If we want to write the same code, same logic
in c++, then there is not much difference.
Instead of using these two functions malloc and
free, we will use two operators new and delete
and write our code something like this. So instead
of using malloc, they are using the new operator
here. And instead of using free we are using
delete here. If we want to allocate an array, we
use something like this where we put the size in
brackets here. And if we want to free an array,
we use this particular operator delete
and two brackets, sorry, one bracket.
With c++ we do not have to do all these typecast
things like malloc returns void and we need to
typecast it back to integer pointer, new undelete
operators are type safe. What it means is that
they're used with a type and return pointers
to a particular type only. So here we will
get a pointer to integer only, we will be talking
about dynamic memory allocation and other library
functions in more detail in the coming lessons.
So thanks for watching. In our previous lesson, we
learned the concept of dynamic memory allocation,
we learnt about stack and heap in the context of
applications memory. In this lesson, we will be
looking at various library functions available
in C for dynamic memory allocation. We will look
through these functions. In some code examples.
We will be talking about three functions that
allocate block of memory on the heap. And these
functions are malloc, calloc and realloc. And
we will also be talking about one function that
D allocates a block of memory on the heap and this
function is three. Let us first talk about malloc.
This is the most frequently used library function
for dynamic memory allocation. And the signature
or the definition of this function is
something like this. This function as
argument asks you for the size of the memory block
in bytes. This data type size underscore t if you
are not aware of it is a data type that stores
all the positive integer values. So, you can
think of this particular data type as unsigned
integer data type, the size cannot be a negative
value it cannot either be zero or a positive
value. And to force this kind of behavior,
we use this particular type. And this
function malloc returns a void pointer,
we have talked about word pointer in our previous
lessons malloc returns a void pointer that gives
us the address of the first byte in this
block the block of memory that it allocates.
So using malloc, you kind of say that, hey,
give me a block of memory with these many
bytes. Let us say what we have here in the right
is the heap section of memory available to us.
Each of these partitions are one byte. As we
know each byte in the memory has an address,
let us say this bottommost byte has the address
to 00. And the next byte is 201. And we go on
increasing towards the top, I'll mark these
among the address of some of these bytes.
Let's say in our code, we make a
call to malloc something like this,
that, hey, give me a block of memory.
That is four bytes. Let's say we store
the address returned by malloc in a void pointer
variable. Now let's assume that this particular
rectangular block that we're showing here in the
read is what gets allocated against this call to
malloc These are four bytes the starting address
is 208. So what will be the address and P if we
want to print the address and p, then what
will be the output, the output will be 208.
This is cool. Using malloc, we are able to
allocate some amount of memory deserves some
amount of memory. But why do we resolve memory,
we reserve or allocate memory because we want
to store some data there. So we do not want to
just randomly allocate some number of bytes. So
although it is correct to write a statement like
this, in practice, we would not do so in practice,
we would first calculate how much amount of memory
we need to store our data. So let's say we want to
store an integer, just one in teacher. So I need
memory blog equal to the size of one integer.
So we typically use the function size off, which
returns us the size of a variable and bytes
to figure out the size of the data type. And
then we typically multiply this particular value
returned by size of by the number of units
that we need. So if we need just one integer,
if we need memory for just one integer, and
this is good, if we need memory for 10 integers,
we would write something like this, give me 10
into size of integer. integer is a primitive data
type. Sometimes you may know that I know that size
of integer is four bytes. So I can write something
like 10 into four here, but it's not a good
practice to do. So, size of a variable depends
upon the compiler. And we will also be using
malloc to allocate memory for complex data types.
So we must use malloc. Like this. Total number of
bytes should be written as number of elements into
size of one unit, one unit of the data. Let's
say if you want to have space for three integers,
I have picked up three so that I have enough
enough space to allocate memory in the figure that
I'm showing here. Let's say this block of 12 bytes
is allocated because size of integer is four bytes
typically, so the starting address would
be 201. Now, how do we fill in data here,
if you see malloc returns a void pointer and
void pointer as such cannot be dereferenced
you cannot write a statement something
like asterik p is equal to two.
This is incorrect, you cannot dereference
a void pointer wide pointer in fact is only
used as a generic pointer type which is normally
typecasted into a pointer type of a particular
data type. And then it is used because malloc
itself is a generic function to allocate
some number of bytes in memory in heap. It does
not care where whether you are allocating this
memory to store character or to store integer or
to store any other data type. It simply returns
a void pointer to the starting address. To be
able to use this block of memory we first need to
typecast this void pointer into a pointer of some
data type. So here we will write something like
Hanes Star p, instead of picking up a void
pointer, we pick up a pointer to integer
because we want to operate with integers, so to
dereference, we need an integer pointer type. So
we do the typecasting here of the void pointer
pointer. And now this statement is valid.
If we want to assign some value to the second
element, second integer in this list, then we
will do something like we will dereference the
address p plus one, let's say we write the value
four here. And if we want to access the third
integer, then we will write something like this.
Let's set the value of sex here. By asking for a
memory block. For three integers, we are basically
creating an array of integers with three elements,
we could also write this as strict p as P zero.
And we could also write as strict p plus one as
p one. And similarly as strict p plus two SP to
the mean the same. All the manipulation on
dynamically allocated memory happens through
pointers, you have a pointer to the starting
address. And then if you want to go to the next
element in the array, you increment the pointer.
And this is how things happen. We have two more
functions that allocate block of memory.
Let us now talk about calloc. The signature
or definition of calloc is something like this
calloc also does the same stuff as malloc, it is
only a slightly different calloc also returns
void pointer. But calloc takes two arguments,
instead of one argument, it takes two arguments.
The first argument is the number of elements
of a particular data type. And the second
argument is the size of the data type.
So with malloc, if we have to declare an array
of size three, an integer array of size three,
we would say three into size of int. With
callot, we would say something like this,
the first argument is how many units of the data
type you want, or the number of elements. And
the second argument is the size of data type in
bytes. There is one more difference between malloc
and calloc. When malloc allocate some amount of
memory, it does not initialize the bytes with
any value. So if you do not fill in any value into
these addresses allocated by malloc, you will have
some garbage there. But if you allocate memory
through calloc calloc sets all byte positions with
value zero, so it also initializes the memory that
it allocates to zero. The third function that we
want to talk about is realloc. If you have a block
of memory, dynamically allocated block of memory,
and if you want to change the size of this
block of memory, then you can use realloc.
The definition or the signature of this particular
function is this function takes two arguments. The
first argument is pointed to the starting address
of the existing block. And the second argument is
the size of the new block, there can be a couple
of cases in relock, the size of the new block
that we want may be larger than than the size
of the previous block. In that case, machine
may create an entirely new block and copy the
previous data, whatever bytes was written in the
previous block into the new block, if contiguous
or consecutive memory is already available
with the existing block and the existing
block may also be extended. Let us now look at
some code examples and see what we can do with
these three functions. And we will discuss the
function three in our code itself. I'll write some
C code and look at some of the use cases in which
we can use dynamic memory allocation. The first
use cases let us say we want to declare an array.
And we want to first asks the user the size of
the array and then we want to declare an array
exactly of this particular size entered by
the user. So let's say I have a variable
n and I write a print statement like enter size
of array and then I input this number n from the
console. Now I want to declare an array of size n
only. So can I do something like this? Well, no,
this particular value in the braces cannot be a
variable this will give you a compilation error,
we need to know the size of the array we cannot
know the size of the array during runtime.
In such a scenario, we can allocate the memory
dynamically. So we will write something like
in Star A is equal to and we will make a
call to malloc to allocate a memory block
equal to the size of an integers. And this will
again give a compilation error unless we typecast
this particular the return of malloc to integer
pointer and now we have an array of size n and
we can fill in some data into the dynamically into
the elements of this dynamically allocated array.
Let's say we want to put data something like first
element is one, and the second element is two,
and so on. So we will write something like a i is
equal to i plus one, we can print the elements in
the array. Let's say we want to pick up size of
array as then. Okay, so the output is as expected,
we have 10 elements from one to 10. If
I give size of array as let's say 25,
then this is what we get, we
get all the elements till 25.
If we wanted to use calloc, instead of
malloc. Here, the only change in this
code would be that we would use calloc
here, and we would have two arguments,
and would separate out as first argument and
the second argument would be size of int.
And this program will run around seamlessly. There
is one more difference between malloc and calloc.
If we do not use this initialization, then with
calloc, as you can see, all the elements are
being printed as zero, they're all initialized
to zero. But if we were using malloc here,
then these elements are not initialized, there is
some garbage value at each of these indices in the
array. So this is one difference between malloc
and calloc calloc initializes fills the value
zero into each byte while malloc doesn't do this
initialization. I'll rewrite this initialization
loop again. And now we will talk about free any
memory that is dynamically allocated remains
allocated till the lifetime of the program till
the time the program is executing, unless you
explicitly D allocated and to deallocate memory
allocated using malloc and calloc or relock,
we have the function three and to the function
free, you just pass the starting address of the
memory block as argument. Now what will happen
if I free a, if we free a then the data from that
memory is erased, it may or may not be erased, it
actually depends upon your compiler or machine.
But that memory will be available for a location
against another call to malloc. Let's say let's
see what happens in this case when we are printing
after freeing that particular memory block, I give
array sizes five and as you can see the elements
being printed here, there is some garbage value
being printed. If this tree was not there, we
would have printed elements 12345 as initialized.
Now the obvious question would be even though
we are freeing the memory here, we are able to
access that the value at that particular memory
location using the statement when we are using AI
the element at index i Well, that is one dangerous
thing about pointers. If you know the address,
you can look at the value at that address. But
you should read and write to that address only
if that address is allocated to you. What if that
address is not allocated to you like in this case?
Well, you do not know what you are reading
or what you're writing. And what we have
here it will have, it actually depends upon
the compiler and the machine. In my case,
let's say after freeing we try to access the third
element a two and try to push some value there.
Let's see what happens if we run this program.
Let's give size of arrays five again, if you see
even after free, we are able to modify the value
at this particular address a two part on some
machine such a program may cause our program to
crash, we should always be sure to use the memory
that is allocated. Otherwise, it's like shooting
in the dark. We do not know what will happen.
We will not talk about Maria Alok. If we want
to modify the size of a memory block. Let's say
we have a memory block to store n elements in an
array. And we want to extend it to maybe we want
to double the size of the array. Or maybe we
want to reduce the size of the array to half.
For such scenario we use real lock and call
to Ria lock will be something like this.
Let's say we take another pointer variable b
then to relock we pass the previous pointer a
and size of the new block. So the new block is
two into n into size of int and we'll have calls
to of course do the typecasting here okay now
what this call will do is it will create a new
memory block of size to n and copy the values in
the previous block in the previous memory block a
into this new memory block. how realloc works is
that if the size of the new block is greater than
the size of the previous block, then if it is
possible to extend the previous block find some
constitutive memory with the same block. Then
the previous block itself is extended. Else.
A new block is allocated and the previous block
the content from the previous block is copied
and the previous block is d allocated this
will become further clear if I write this
print statement. I'll print the previous block
address stored in a and the new address stored
in B and I'll also print all the two elements in
B now, and I'll print each element in the array
B in one single line. Let's say size of there is
five again. Okay, so the previous block address is
9920128. And if you see the new address is also
same. So it was possible to extend the previous
block only. And in B, the first five elements are
from a and rest five elements are garbage value.
If we wanted to reduce the array size to let's
say, half the same block, the previous block
itself will be reduced. So let's say I want to
print the previous block now, the n elements.
Now as you can see, the first two elements
are copied one and two, they're not copied,
in fact, they are there already, the rest three
are de allocated. When we divide five by two,
we take only the integral part. So we kind of
deallocate the space for three elements here.
In fact, if we give the size to be zero, here, all
that will happen is that the complete block four
a will be de allocated. So this statement
will be equivalent to using free upon a.
In most cases, we will put the return address
by realloc into the same integer pointer.
so we can write instead of writing B here we can
write a also, we can also pass the first argument
to realloc as null if the first argument
is null, and the second argument is size.
And let's say we want to create something like a
new block, with address starting at a stored in B,
that is the first argument is null, then
this is equivalent to calling a malloc.
This only creates a new block does not
copy anything from the previous block.
So realloc can be used with the right arguments
as substitute for free as well as as substitute
for malloc. This was all about malloc,
calloc, realloc. And free, we will see more
code on dynamic memory allocation in the coming
lessons. So thanks for watching. In this lesson,
we will talk about pointers as return types. For
functions. A pointer is just another data type.
It's just that a pointer stores the address
of another data type. So it is quite possible
for a function to return pointer. But we must
understand the use cases in which we may want to
return a pointer from a function. So let us try
to understand this. I'll get started by writing
some code. Now I want to write a very simple C
program. Initially, I want to write a function
ad that will take two integers as argument
and sum these two numbers and return the sum.
So let's say we declare another variable c and c
is equal to a plus b and the function returns C.
Now in the main method, I'll initialize two
variables. Let's name these variables x and y,
let's say x is equal to two and y is equal to
four. And we will have another variable said,
which will be the return of this function
ad. And we will pass x and y as arguments to
this function. And finally, I'll print something
like sum is equal to Zed. No prizes for guessing
the output here. I'll modify this code slightly.
But before that, I want to talk about this concept
once again, that x, y and Zed are local variables
to main function, and a, b and c are local to add
function. And what really happens when we call
the add function is that value in this variable
x of Maine is copied to variable a of add,
and value in y of Maine is copied to b of ad.
And what if we named these variables in
Maine, A, B, and C instead of x, y and Zed
if we run this code output will be the same. This
time, what we will say is that the value in a of
Maine is copied to a of ad and the value in B of
Maine is copied to b of ad, this a in Maine and
this a in AD, they are not the same. You can
verify this by printing something like this.
I'm printing the addresses of these two A's in
my code. And as you can see, our address of A
in Maine is something like 2883032 and in
AD it is 2882792 so they're not the same.
That means these variables are not the same they
are at different memory addresses and the names of
variables are local or specific to a particular
function. In our example, here, the method the
function mean can be called calling function and
the function ad can be called called function.
In this particular call, when we are saying that c
is equal to AD and passing a and b, and this call
where a and b in Maine are getting copied to
a and b in AD. This is called Called by value,
this can be called a call by value. Now, what
I want to do is instead of passing by value,
I want to pass the addresses of these two
variables. So, I want to say that I want
to pass address of A and address of b to
the add function. So, the signature of add
function should be such that it should receive
the addresses. So, I will say that, okay,
it takes two pointer to integers A and B. And
now, we can access the values at these addresses
by using this Asterix operator which is used to
date reference and address. Now such a call is
called call by reference, a and b are integers
local to main function and in the function
ad, A and B are not integer variables, A and
B are pointer variables pointer to integers.
So the type is different. They're not in
their int star. But at the end of the day,
they are also variables which are local to the
function add. It's just that they're not integers.
And now I'm using these two variables which are
pointer to integers to access these two variables
a and b in the main method, and to do so we use
the asterik operator and now this code should
also work. I'll write a few more print statements
inside this function add. I have tried to print
a and I have tried to print Astra K. And
initially I was printing ampersand A.
So now ampersand a should give us the address of
the pointer variable a should give us the address
of A in Maine because that is what this variable
stores and asterik A should give us the value of
A in Maine let us see. And the output. As you can
see here, the address of A in Maine is 3537612.
And address of A in AD is something else, but
the value in a of ad, which is the address of
a of Maine is equal to 353762. So the first
and the third line are same. And using the
address we are printing the value, which is
equal to two I had a spelling mistake here.
Now I'll clean up some of these print statements
coming back to our function ad we are returning
this value C and once again in the main method we
are collecting this value seen another variable
which is C of main why not do something like pass
the address of this C in add function. So what
we will do now is we will say that we want to
return a pointer to integer from this function.
And here we will return ampersand see now
ampersand operator when it is put in front of
a variable it gives us the address. Now of course
here we will have to collect this particular
address. So we will have to define a pointer
variable. Now this would be okay. And when we
are printing, we will have to print the value at
address being pointed to by this pointer variable.
So what we just did was, what we just did is we
modified this add function to return a pointer
to integer there are two syntax, we can say int
and then put this Asterix sign or we can say int
and then put this Asterix and in front of the
function name, ad and what the syntax are valid.
Now this function is returning pointer to integer.
Let us run this program and see what happens.
Well, let me also strike off this print statement
here. Okay, so the output seems to be all right.
Now have you got some logical error with this
code already? If you haven't, stay with me for
some time. Now what I want to do is I want
to write another function, a simple function
that will print hello world. So I'll name this
function print hello world. And in this function,
I'll write a simple print statement. And now
before I print the sum, what I'll do is I'll
call this function print hello world. And let's
see what happens now. Oops, this looks weird.
Some is not correct. Now, I just saw that it
was coming fine in my last run when I did not
call this print hello world. What happened? So
let's try to understand what really happened here.
I'll come back to this family a diagram of various
sections of applications memory, and the memory
that is allocated to a program is typically
divided into these sections, all the local
variables, and the information about function
call executions goes into the stack. So let us
run through this code. Let us simulate this code
and see what's really happening in the memory.
For each function calls some part of the memory
from the stack is allocated for its execution. We
call this the stack frame of that method or that
function when the program starts executing for
The main method is invoked. So in the stack frame,
some memory will be allocated for main function,
and all the local variables of main function
will live inside this stack frame. Let's say
the starting address of this stack frame is 100.
And the end address of the stack frame is 130. And
we will have three local variables created here,
A, B and PTR. a and b are integers and PTR is an
integer pointer, let's say is at address 100, b
is at address 112. And PTR is at address 120. I'm
just making these assumptions. Now when the main
method will come at this line will where it is
calling ad function, its execution will pause and
now memory will be allocated for the execution of
ad at any time whatever function is at the top
of stack is executing main method will wait for
add function to complete and return. So here I
should say a is equal to two b is equal to four.
And now add comes here in the stack, let's say
add gets memory from 130 to 160. And add also
has three local variables a B and C A and B are
pointers to integers, the value of a will be 100
and the value of B will be 112. Let's say their
addresses his addresses are 130 140 and 144.
Once again these are just random assumptions. Now
see is calculated as asterik A plus asterik b A
is pointing to this location and B is pointing to
this location asterik is value at address stored
in a and astrick B's value at address stored in B
so this C will be six here these two values will
be added. Now this add function will return the
address of its local variable C which is 144 and
finish its execution. So this PTR will be 144 and
now the memory that is allocated to add function
will be de allocated. Now this memory above
address 130 can be used for other function calls.
And even though this variable pointer PTR
stores the address 144 stores the address
of this particular block it kind of points to this
particular block. The data here is not guaranteed
because this memory has been de allocated. Now
we come here to this print hello world. And now
a memory from stack will be allocated for
print hello world. Above this stack frame
of main method. This is main. So let's say
that print HelloWorld gets this memory block
from address 132 address 150. But there is no
local variable in this print hello world function.
But still function call execution involves storage
of some information. So now this section from 130
to 150 is for print hello world, I'll write
pH Ws shortcut for print HelloWorld. And it
has been overwritten. So this block at 144 no
more stores a value of six. So when we come here
at this print statement to print the value at this
particular address, we get some garbage value. Now
the obvious question would be why did the diode
Why did we get the right value, when we were not
making a call to print hello world, I would say
that I just got lucky maybe because I did not
call any other function after making a call to add
my machine did not overwrite or erase the data at
that particular memory location. But when I made
a call to print HelloWorld that memory got used.
If you see we have passed the addresses of these
two variables a and b of Maine to add function,
but that is all right because called function
always comes above the calling function in
the stack. So anytime this called function is
executing calling function will be in the memory.
So if ad is executing main is guaranteed to be
in the memory. So addresses of variables in Maine
will be accessible to add. But if we try to return
a local variable from the call function back to
the calling function, like if we want to return
a local variable from add to main, then when that
function finishes and the control returns back
to the calling function, that memory has already
been de allocated. So it is okay to pass something
from bottom to top in this call stack. Or I should
rather say that it's okay to pass a local variable
the address of a local variable from bottom to top
in this stack but it is not okay to return the
address of a local variable from top to bottom
in the stack in the call stack. I hope this
makes sense. So now the obvious question would
be what are the use cases in which we may want to
return pointers from functions and well if we have
address of some memory block in the heap section
or some memory block in the global section,
then we can safely return that address Have
these blocks because anything in the heap has
to be explicitly de allocated we control it's
D allocation unlike stack. And anything which
is in the global section, a global variable
lives, for the entire lifetime of the program,
I can use malloc or new operator in c++ to get
some memory on heap. So, if I modify my code
something like this, I will declare this C as a
pointer to integer and get some space allocated
on the heap using a call to malloc. Now malloc
is a library function that returns a pointer,
but it returns a pointer to an address which
is on the heap. So, we get a memory block and
using this pointer variable now, we can write this
value asterik A plus astrick b at that particular
memory block and then we can return this address C
which is the same address that malloc returned us,
but we are safe now because we are returning
address of a block which is on the heap and and
not on the stack and this will work now. Now in
this code, let's say this call to malloc gives us
this block at address 500 in the heap see now
is only pointing to this block and using C we
have written this data here this value six and
now when add finishes, the address returned by
the add function which is address 500 is still
valid and we still have the data there and it
will not be de allocated anything on the heap
is explicitly has to be explicitly de allocated.
So while returning pointers from functions, we
need to be careful about the scope, we must be
sure that the address is not reused to store
something else or the data is not cleared from
that address. In most cases we will be returning
pointers to memory that is allocated on the heap,
or memory that is in the global section the global
variables section. In our coming lessons one place
where we will be using pointers as function
returns in our code is implementation of
linked list data structure. So this was pointers
as function returns. Thanks for watching.
In this lesson, we are going to talk about
function pointers. function pointers,
as the name suggests, are used to store address
of functions. So far, we have used pointers mostly
as variables that would store address of other
variables. Basically, pointers are data types
that can be used to store the address of some data
stored in computer's memory, or in other words
to point to or refer to some data. And it doesn't
always have to be a variable data could be stored
as constant also. And we use pointers not just to
store the address, we can dereference and get the
value at whatever address the pointer is pointing
to. Now we are saying that we can have pointers
that can store address or functions or in other
words can point to functions. And we can use a
pointer to function to dereference and execute
the function. And this is really interesting.
Some basic questions would pop up what really
would be the address of a function. And even
if we can have pointers to functions, what are
the use cases in which we may want to have them?
There are really interesting use cases of function
pointers, but we will talk about them later.
Let's first try to understand the core logic here.
Once again, I have drawn this familiar diagram,
the memory that is allocated to an application
or a program can typically be divided into
these four segments. We have talked about
this quite a bit in our previous lessons.
Okay, now a program is basically a set or
sequence of instructions that you would give
to the computer to perform a task, we can write
our program in a high level language like C
or c++, but at lowest level in its architecture,
computer understands and executes only binary,
any instruction that has to be executed by the
computer has to be encoded in binary. Of course,
there will be some rules for encoding. So what we
do is we write our program or set of instructions
in a high level language like C or c++, and we
pass it to a program called compilers as input
and corresponding to the source code compiler
generates what we call machine code, or executable
code, which is instructions encoded in binary.
Something like what I'm trying to show here.
compiler basically takes one or more source files.
Let's say the program that I have written here is
in a file named program dot c. Now a compiler for
C language will take this file as input and create
an executable file that will have the machine code
on a Windows machine executable file has extension
e x e, an executable file will be stored in
disk drive or some secondary storage device.
Whenever we say memory, just memory in context
of programming, we mean the random access memory
or RAM that we also call the main memory or
primary storage. So whatever applications memory
we're talking about here will be a chunk of main
memory. A program or application gets a chunk of
memory only when it starts execution. When the
application finishes execution, this memory is
claimed back. What really happens is that when we
run a program, when a program starts execution,
some amount of memory is allocated to it. And that
is what we are calling applications memory. Here.
The cold or text segment of applications memory
is basically the machine code or instructions
copied from the executable file. Instructions
are not executed directly from secondary storage.
Therefore, they are first copied to main memory,
and then only they can be executed. During program
execution, we need memory not just to store
instructions to be executed, but also to store
a lot of data that we would work upon in a
program. These other segments are mostly about
storing and managing data. What I'm going to
do now is I'm going to zoom into the code or
text segment, let's assume that each
instruction in machine language takes
four bytes. I'm trying to show the section
of memory storing the instructions here,
each partition here is a block of four bytes
and addresses increasing from top to bottom.
So, we have instruction zero at address 200.
And the next instruction is at address 204.
And the next is at 208. And so on, instructions
in a program are executed sequentially.
Only Exception will be when instruction itself
will say that hey go to or jump to this other
instruction at this particular address, which will
happen in case of function calls. For example,
if instructions 01 Nat address 200 is currently
executing By default, the next instruction to
be executed is instruction 02 at address 204
unless instructions 01 itself is something like
go to instruction 05 at address 216 which will
happen in case of function calls. A function
is nothing but a set of instructions
stored in one contiguous block of memory.
Let's say this block containing instructions five
till eight is a function. I'll name this function
if you and see one. Basically, a function is
a set of instructions to perform a sub task
in memory a function will be one contiguous
block with some instructions, the address of
a function what we also call entry point of
a function will be the address of the first
instruction in the function. In this example here,
address of function one is 216. a function call in
machine language will basically be an instruction
to jump to entry point of some function to jump to
first instruction in a function. Now we will not
go any deeper into architecture now this is good
enough to understand function pointers. When we
say function pointers store address of functions,
we basically mean that function pointers store
the starting address or entry point of the block
of memory containing all the instructions in a
function. Let's now see how we can create and
use function pointers in a C or c++ program. I am
going to write a simple C program here. The first
thing that I'm going to do is I'm going to write
a function named ad. That will take two integers
as argument and return the sum of these two
integers. And now I'm going to create a function
pointer that should point to this function
add. The syntax to create function pointer is,
first type in the return type of the
function to which this pointer will point
at will return int so I typed in int, then
after space within paranthesis, type in
Asterix, and then name of the variable so I'm
creating a pointer named P. And now once again
within paranthesis. Type in all the argument types
of the function to which this pointer will point.
argument types in function declaration should be
exactly the same as in the function to which this
pointer will point. Because both arguments
in add function are int, we have two ends
in the declaration of function pointer also,
to initialize function pointer and fill in
the address of a function we can use a statement
like this. As we know ampersand operator gives us
the address of something. This statement p equal
ampersand ad will fill in the address of ad in P.
So P now points to AD. And using p, we can execute
this function ad. What I'm going to do here is I'm
going to declare an integer variable named C. And
now I'm going to write a statement like this. What
I've done here is first I have used the Asterix
operator to dereference and get the function.
And then I have passed arguments just like I
would do with a function name. So I've passed
two integers two and three. And if everything is
alright, the output of this printf statement here
should be integer value five, when I
run the program, this is what I get.
So, this is really cool, we just used a
function pointer to refer to a function
and then execute the function. One thing about
the syntax of function pointer declaration,
we are putting the identifier or name of the
pointer within this paranthesis if we would not
use the paranthesis then it will mean that we are
declaring a function that will return a pointer
to integer in this case, if I would write
something like this, I would write a declaration
something like this, then this is declaring a
function that would return a pointer to integer
we can have an Asterix just before the function
name or we can have an Asterix just after int
these two syntax are same, but if I would put
this within paranthesis then this is declaring a
function pointer. Okay, a few more things. In this
initialization Here we are using this ampersand
operator. Even if we do not use this ampersand
operator, it will mean the same just using the
function name will also return us address of the
function or in other words and appropriate pointer
to data friends, instead of using this paranthesis
and Asterix operator with function pointer name,
we can simply use the function pointer name
and this is good enough. So we can use function
pointer name or identifier just like function
name, as you can see the output here is as
expected. So, we have two possible syntax for
both referencing and dereferencing you can use
whichever you like the second one is more famous,
one final thing to be able to point to a function
type of the function pointer must be appropriate.
So in this declaration of P here if I would change
it something like this, then this function pointer
is meant to point to a function that should take
two integers as argument and should return void
add function is returning int, so P cannot point
to add this will give me compile ation error.
Once again, if I will change the declaration
something like this, if I will have only one
argument in the declaration of function pointer,
then P cannot point to add. Okay, now let's use
some more functions with different signatures
and try to execute them through function
pointers. I'm writing this function print hello,
it will simply print hello on screen. And we will
have to declare a function pointer like this.
And then we can initialize the pointer and fill
in the address of this function. And now we can
execute the function through the pointer. Let's
see what the output is. This looks alright.
Now let's say we want to say hello to someone
and I'll change the signature of print hello,
to take a string as argument the declaration
of a function pointer will also change
and while calling we will have to pass a
string upon running this program, this is
what I get. And this is also looking fine. So this
is pretty much how we can create and use function
pointers in C or c++ function pointers are used
in a program in interesting scenarios. They have
interesting use cases. We will talk about the use
cases in next lesson. This is it for this lesson.
Thanks for watching. In our previous lesson,
we saw what function pointers are. And then we
wrote a simple program to understand how we can
create function pointers in C or c++ program. But
we did not discuss the real use cases of function
pointers, real scenarios where function pointers
can be useful. So in this lesson, we are going
to talk about the use cases of function pointers.
All the use cases of function pointers are
around this concept that function pointers can
be passed as arguments to functions. And then a
function that would receive a function pointer as
argument can call back the function that this
pointer will point to. To explain this better,
I will have to write some code. First of all,
I'm going to write a simple function named
a dysfunction. No argument returns void and
simply prints Hello on screen. Now I will write
another function named p, this function takes
a function pointer as argument PTR should point
to a function that should take no argument and
should return void of function like a. Now in B,
I will simply use this function pointer PTR to
call whatever function it's pointing to. Or in
other words, I can say that I will call back the
function passed to me or given to me through PTR.
In the main function, I will declare a function
pointer. And this function pointer should also
point to a function that should take no argument
and should return void. I will initialize this
function pointer p with address of A. And now
I will call this function be passing it this
function pointer P. Let's run this program and see
what happens. Hello is getting printed on screen.
So, basically function a is getting executed,
a is getting executed through this callback.
In the main function instead of writing
these two statements, I can simply write
a statement like this and this should be good
enough, because name of a function we had
discussed this earlier also returns a pointer.
So, this one statement is same as previous two
statements, when reference to a function is passed
to another function, then that particular function
is called a callback function. So, a is a callback
function here, it can be called back by B through
the reference through the function pointer.
This statement where we are calling the function
through function pointer is a callback, we are
still not doing something very meaningful here.
What's the point in calling a indirectly through
B in this code, this is not making much sense.
So let's now look at a scenario where using a
function pointer and callback can make our life
easier. I have a simple scenario, I have a list of
integers in an array, and I want to sort this list
in increasing order of the value of integers.
To do so I will write my own sort function,
I'm writing a function named sort that will take
an array and number of elements in the array,
the function will take an integer array,
here I can write a and then brackets or
I can write Asterix a these two are alternate
syntax, I will use simple bubble sort algorithm,
I have renamed this function as bubble sort. In
bubble sort, we make multiple passes on an array.
And in each pass as we go from left to right,
as we go from lower indices to higher indices,
we compare adjacent elements. And if the element
at lower index is greater than the element at
higher index, while comparing adjacent elements,
then we swap the elements, this inner loop
is a pass on array. And this outer loop is
basically saying that we will make n passes
after first pass the largest element in the
list will bubble up to the highest index,
and in the next pass, the second largest
will bubble up to its appropriate position,
this will go on and it finally in n passes, the
complete list will be sorted. If you want to
refresh bubblesort. There is a link to my
code schools lesson on bubble sort in the
description of this video. In the main function
I have called bubblesort function passing it
array A, and then I'm printing all the elements
in a and hopefully elements should be printed in
increasing order. The output is as expected, we
have a sorted list here. Okay, now let's say I
want to sort my list in decreasing order of the
value of integers. So what change should go in
my code here? Think about it. The only change will
be in this comparison logic in this if statement,
while comparing the adjacent elements. Now, I will
say that if the element in left is smaller, if the
element at lower index is smaller than swap, or
basically, in 10, push it towards higher index,
comparing adjacent elements and swapping is
basically pushing smallest or largest element
towards higher indices. With this condition.
With this comparison, we are pushing the smaller
number towards higher index. Let's see the output
now. As you can see, I'm getting the numbers in
decreasing order. Now my list is sorted in
decreasing order of the value of integers.
Now let's say I have a requirement like this.
Sometimes in my program, I want to sort a list
of integers in increasing order. And sometimes
I want to sort a list in decreasing order of the
value of integers. So what all can I do? Think
about it. One thing that I can do is I can write
To start functions, the first sort function
to sort in increasing order and another sort
function to sort in decreasing order. But if we
will do so there will be a lot of duplicate code,
the two functions will be same, except
just one character this less than sign,
or greater than sign. Writing duplicate code has
a lot of disadvantages. So can we do something
better. Another thing that we can do is we can
pass one more parameter to the sort function to
say whether we want the list sorted in increasing
order or decreasing order, we can have a flag,
let's say when flag is one, we will start in
increasing order and when flag is zero, we will
start in decreasing order. Using this approach,
we can avoid writing a lot of duplicate code.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to use
a function pointer. Sorting off a list is
always done on basis of some ranking mechanism.
So based on some property, we should be able to
compare elements and say that they should come
first and they should come later, the core
logic in sorting will always be the same. Only the
ranking mechanism or comparison logic will change.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to decide which
element is greater in rank and which element is
lesser through a function, basically, I will
perform this comparison through a function,
my function will take a function pointer as
argument, my sort function will take function
pointer as argument, the callback function, or
the function that this pointer should point to,
must take two integers as argument, it should
compare the two integers, and then it should
return back an integer. It should return
one if first element has higher rank
zero if the elements are equal, and minus
one if second element or second argument
has higher rank. And let's say the element
that has higher rank will go towards the end
in sorted array towards higher indices. These are
my assumptions while designing this sort function.
Now I'm going to use my callback function for
comparison, if AJ and AJ plus one are now passed
as arguments to this callback function, and
we get one, so this condition will be true,
we will swap in this condition because AJ will
have to be higher in rank for this comparison
function to return one. So we will try to push
a j towards higher indices. Let's now try to use
this particular implementation of bubblesort,
I will have to write a callback function first,
I have written a function like this. Now in main,
I can just use the name of this function that will
return me a function pointer and pass it in this
call to bubblesort. In this comparison function,
I have not written a statement to return zero if
elements are equal. Equality doesn't matter in the
logic, so far equality also I will return minus
one. Let's first run this program and see the
output. This is what I'm getting the numbers
are sorted in increasing order. Now I will
change the comparison logic a bit, I will return
minus one if a is greater than b. So basically,
I have changed the ranking mechanism, the
element with lower value is now ranked higher,
and will go towards the end of the array. This
is what I'm getting upon running the program.
The array is now sorted in decreasing order of
the value of integers. This is a really good
design because now our sort function can sort a
list of integers based on any ranking mechanism,
we can have one callback function for each
ranking mechanism. I will take one more
example. Let's say we have a list of integers
with both positive and negative values in it,
I have modified a here a now has both positive
and negative values, this time I want to sort this
array in increasing order of the absolute value
of integers. So the negative sign will not matter,
we will just take a mod and then compare
this array upon sorting should rearrange like
this. To be able to sort I will have to write a
comparison function. Last time, we had modified
the same compare function, but actually we
should be writing one comparison function
for each sorting scenario. So I will write a new
function this time, I will write a function named
named absolute compare. I have included a
reference to math dot h library and I will use
a BS function from this library that will give me
absolute value of an integer. If absolute value of
a is greater than absolute value of b, then it's
ranked higher, I should return one else I should
return minus one. Let's now use this function to
solve This array, I have a minus spell error here.
Okay, instead of passing this compare function,
I will now pass absolute compare in this call
to bubblesort. This basically is passing
a pointer to absolute compare function.
Let's now run this program and see what happens.
This is what I'm getting the elements are sorted
in increasing order of their absolute values.
The bubble sort function here can take only an
array of integers, but we have a library function
that can take any array. So it's further generic.
This library function is in STD
lib dot h library. And it's named
q SOT q SOT for quicksort and to this function
you should pass an array and it can be any array
it can be an array of integers or it can be an
array of characters or even a complex data type or
structured first argument will be the array second
argument will be number of elements in array,
third argument will be the size of the data type.
So if this is an array of integers, I need to pass
size of int, size of data type in bytes size
of function gifts, size of any data type in
bytes. last argument should be a function pointer
a pointer to compare comparison function signature
of the comparison function should be like this, it
should take two constant void pointers as argument
and return an integer. Why word pointers? What
pointers are generic pointers, we can typecast
them to a pointer of any data type. And this
is the specification of Q sort function,
it should be passed a pointer to such a
function, so it will be able to call it
back. Let's write the comparison function. You
can think of this as a reference of first element
passed as a void pointer to get the element.
If it's a list of integers, I'll first have to
typecast the void pointer to int pointer. And
then I'll have to use the Asterix operator to
dereference and get the value, we will do the same
to get the value of second element, this function
must return any positive integer, if A is ranked
higher, a negative integer if A is ranked lower,
and zero if both are ranked same, we can simply
return A minus B and it will mean the same. If
A is higher in value, A minus B will be positive.
And I'm trying to create a simple comparison
function here that would rank and integer with
higher value as high. So basically this comparison
function can be used to sort the array in
increasing order of value of integers. So,
like I said, returning positive value means a
is ranked higher returning negative value means
B is ranked higher with this comparison
function, if I would simply pass this to
Q sort and after the call to cusat print the
value in this array, this is what I will get
as you can see the list is sorted in
increasing order of the value of integers.
If I will change this comparison function to
return b minus a. So element with lesser value
integer with lesser value will be ranked higher,
the list will be sorted in decreasing order of the
value of integers. And if I will use abstract
absolute value of A minus absolute value of b,
this is what I will get. Remember, in this
comparison function, the two elements to be
compared are being passed through reference, their
addresses are being passed through a pointer. The
const keyword here means you cannot modify the
address in this pointer variable. We are having
to use void pointer because of generic design of Q
sort function. Remember q SOT can sort any array,
not just an integer array, it's just that you
will have to give the comparison logic. Okay, so
we just discussed one of the use cases of function
pointers. This whole idea of callback is used in
a lot of interesting design scenarios. One more
thing where this concept of callback makes our
life easier is something called event handling. If
you are curious, you can check the description of
this video for some resources on event handling.
This is it for this lesson. Thanks for watching.
In our previous lessons, we have learned
the concept of dynamic memory allocation
we have understood what is stack and what is
heap in applications memory. Now in this lesson
we are going to talk about one situation which is
caused by improper use of dynamic memory or the
memory on the heap and this situation is memory
leak. A quick recap of some of the concepts that
we have discussed in our previous lessons. The
memory that is allocated for the execution of an
of a program or what we can also Call
applications memory is typically divided
into these four segments or these four sections.
One section stores the instructions in the program
that need to be executed. This section is
called the code segment or the text segment.
Another section is used to store the global
variables the variables that are not declared
inside functions and have lifetime of the whole
application. Another section of the memory is
used to execute the function calls and store all
the local variables this section is called stack.
The size of these three segments that code segment
the global variable segment and the stack segment
are fixed and decided when the program is
compiling. That is at the compile time. And the
fourth section, which is called heap, or dynamic
memory does not have a fixed size, heap can grow
as per need. As we know, we get memory from the
heap by making a call to malloc function in C.
And when we are done using that memory on the
heap, we make a call to the free function to
deallocate or free that particular memory. In
c++ apart from malloc. And free, we can also use
the operator new to get some memory and the
operator Delete to free that memory. memory
leak is a situation when we get some memory
on the heap, and do not free it when we are
done using it. So our application is actually
holding on to some unused memory on the heap.
But why do we call this situation memory leak? And
why does it happen due to improper use of dynamic
memory only due to improper use of heap only and
not some other sections of applications memory,
we will try to understand this through
one simple program. So what I'll do is,
I'll write one simple program and show the
simulation of its execution in the memory.
To explain these concepts. In my C program here
I'm going to write a very simple betting game.
And the game is that we have three positions
and three cards, jack, queen and king. Initially
jack is at the first position key queen is at
the second position, and King is at the third
position. And then computer shuffles these cards
so that the positions of these cards is changed
is randomized. And now the player has to guess the
position of the queen, he has to bet some amount
of money. Let's say it's virtual cash. And if he
wins if he predicts the position, if he guesses
the position of Queen correctly, he takes away
three times the amount that he had back. And
if he loses, he simply loses the bet amount. Let's
say the player initially has $100 of virtual cash,
and he can play as many times as he wants until
he runs out of cash. So let us now implement
this game. The first thing that I want to do
is I want to declare a global variable named
cash that at any point will store the virtual cash
available with the player initially he has $100 of
virtual cash. And then in the main method, I will
declare a variable named bet. And I will write
code something like this. While cash is greater
than zero, while player still has some cash,
we will ask him to bet something and we will take
this input in this variable bet using scanf. For
negative scenarios like bet equals zero or bad
being greater than the cash available, let's say
we will break out of this loop we will end our
game for all of the conditions let's say we will
make a call to play function. And of course,
now we will have to write the play function
we will be passing bet to the play function. So
that will be an argument. And now in the play
function I will declare a character
array of size three. And initially,
we will have the character j at the first position
to say that there is a jack at the first position
J is for jack and similarly Q is for Queen
and k is working. And now the computer must
perform a randomized shuffling. So we will write
a print statement like this. Now we need to find
a logic to make a random shuffle of cards. One
such logic is that we can make a call to random
number generator function in C to use the random
number generator. First, we will make a call to s
RAND function and pass it an argument something
like this. I'll come back to what I'm doing here
in a strand by making a call to a strand. Now
let's say we run a loop five times and we will
choose any two random positions among 01 and two
and swap the letter said these positions in the
array. Let's say these positions are x and y. Now
when we make a call to RAND function, we will get
a random number but we want a number between Zero
and two, zero and two included. So we will take a
modulo by three so that we either get zero or one
or two. So we will take two such random positions
with statements like this. And now, what we can do
is we can swap the characters at these positions.
So we will use a temporary variable First, we
will store the character at position x in temp,
and then we will do something like this. I'm
short of space here. So I'm writing three
statements in the same line.
Okay, so now the swapping is done.
So we are swapping or shuffling characters or two
positions, five times each time, we are picking up
two positions x and y are randomly by making call
to RAND function and taking a module by three.
So this will guarantee us that x and y is between
zero and two. That will be valid positions
by making a call to RAND function, we will
get the random numbers but we also use this s
Rand once and pass this time null, the return
of time function in random number generation,
there is something there is one concept of seeding
the random number generators, so we are passing
seed to random number generator, we will not go
into the details of random number generation now.
Now what I'll do in the proof play function is
I'll have a variable named players guess. And
I'll ask the player to guess the position of Queen
and then I will use scanf to take the input. Now
if the player is correct, then the character at
that particular position in the character or a C,
and the position will be one minus what the player
inputs, because the player is inputting one,
two or three that will map to 01 and two in the
array. So if the character is Queen, he has one.
So his overall cash will be incremented by three
times the amount else he has lost, lost, and his
cache will be decremented by the bet amount. So in
the case of when we will write a print statement
like this, we will say that you have one and the
result is this and your total cash, right now is
this. Remember, cash is a global variable. And we
will print something similar if the player loses.
Finally, our play function is looking something
like this. And we have also moved this variable
cash at the top. In the main method, I've
added two more print statements initially.
Let's now play this game and see what happens.
What I have done is I have compiled this code
and created an executable named game dot txt. And
now I'm going to run that executable. So this is
asking, what's your bet. Let's say we want to bet
$5 on position one, and I lose my balance now is
$95. Let's bet again, this time again, I lose. And
I can go on playing some losing again and again.
Finally, a win after long time, I can go
on playing this game, but I want to show
you something else, I have opened the task
manager of Windows. And here. As you can see,
this highlighted row is for game dot e xe. The
third column here is the memory consumed by this
executable game dot e xe you will have to see
this in full screen. Now as I go on playing
the memory consumption here, the memory that
showing you is not increasing, it's always 340 8k.
Now I'll go ahead and make some changes
in my code. What I'll do here is
this particular character array that I'm creating
as a local variable in the play function. Right
now it's created as a local variable, so it will
go on the stack. Now I want to create a character
array on the heap. So what I'll do is, I'll write
a statement like this, I'll declare a character
pointer named C and then I'll use malloc. To
fetch memory to store three character variables.
In c++, we could have said something like this,
we could have used the new operator. And now I'll
set a value at z zero at index as j, one at index
Sq and two at index as K. So we have created an
array on the heap and c is a pointer to the base
address of that array C is still a local variable,
but now it is a pointer to character and we can
still use it like array. The rest of the code
will just work fine. Let us run this code and see
what happens. I have opened the task manager and
I'm running the executable. Watch for the memory
consumption of game dot txt. I will make some bets
as you You can see right now the memory
consumption is 340 8k. I just kept on playing and
after some time the memory consumption is 480 8k,
it has shot up. And if you will keep playing this
game further, after some time it will shoot up
again, or maybe after some time, but it will shoot
up for sure. So why is it happening, or why was it
not shooting up when See, the character array was
not on the stack, not on the heap and it was on
the stack. Let's try to understand, I have drawn
sections of applications memory here. And let us
now see what really happens in the memory when we
are playing our game. As we know from our previous
lessons, all the information about function call
execution goes into the stack section of
the memory. Anytime a function is called
some amount of memory from the stack is allocated
for its execution when the program starts
executing. First, the main method is invoked or
called. So let's say some amount of memory is
allocated for the execution of Maine. This is what
we call the stack frame of a function. So this is
stack frame of Maine and all the local variables
of Maine will sit inside this stack frame in our
code we had a local variable named bet, so it will
go here and we had a global variable named cache.
So initially, let's say main function is executing
when we play our game main function makes multiple
calls to play function. And what really happens
when a function makes call to another function
is that that particular function is paused
and memory is allocated for the execution of
the called function. So main will pause and play
will start executing and play will go on top of
main in the stack. Now, we had a couple of local
variables in play all will go in this stack frame
i x y players guess and for the case
one when we had the character array C
on the stack itself, so it was not created using
a call to malloc the character array C will also
sit in this stack frame. Now when the execution
of play function will finish control will return
back to main and the memory that was allocated for
the execution of play function will be reclaimed.
Anytime a function call finishes, the memory
that it is allocated on the stack is reclaimed.
So there is one stack frame corresponding to
each call. And as soon as that call finishes,
that memory is claimed back. Now main will make
another call to play because we will play multiple
rounds. So play will again come into the stack
and it will be cleared again when play finishes.
As you can see, all the local variables get
cleared each time the function call finishes.
For anything on the stack, we do not have to worry
about its deallocation it happens automatically
when the function call finishes. Now let's talk
about the second case when character array is
created on the heap using a call to malloc
function. Once again we will make multiple calls
to play function. Now, what will happen this time
is that we will not create the array on the stack,
we will still have a variable named c a local
variable named c but this variable will not
be of type character array of size three, this
variable will be of type pointer to character and
we will make a call to malloc function to create
the array on the heap and this local variable
which is a pointer to character will only point
to this particular memory block anything that is
on the heap has to be accessed through a pointer
variable. So here we have created the array on
the heap and we have kept only a pointer variable
on the stack. Now when the call to play function
will finish the memory allocated for the execution
of call to play function will be reclaimed. So all
the local variables will go away. But this memory
on the heap will lie unused and unreferenced and
it will not get d allocated anything on the heap
has to be explicitly D allocated by making a call
to free function or by using delete operator and
think about it we will make multiple calls to play
function as we play multiple rounds of our game.
And each time in each call to play we will create
one such memory block on the heap that will lie
unreferenced and unused when call to play function
will finish. If we will play our game 100 rounds
then we will have hundreds such unreferenced and
unused memory blocks of three characters and
the heap. heap is not fixed in size. And our
application can claim can get more memory in
the heap section as long as our system itself
is not running out of memory. And if we are not
D allocating this unused memory on the heap via
depleting and wasting memory which is an important
resource. Our applications memory consumption will
only keep on growing with time. memory leaks
are really nasty bugs to have in your program.
Anything unused and unreferenced on the heap
is garbage. In C or c++ we have to make sure
as programmers that garbage is not created on the
heap memory leak is nothing but growth of garbage
in the heap. in languages like Java and C sharp
garbage is automatically cleared From the heap,
so a programmer does not have to worry about
freeing or D allocating the memory on heap,
which is a cool feature to have. It avoids memory
leak. In this example, we were creating an array
of three characters on the heap. What if we were
creating an array of 10,000 characters and not
freeing freeing the memory after we were done
using it, at the end of the function, the memory
consumption would have shot up like anything.
Coming back to my code here, what I have done is,
I have created a character array of size 10,000 of
10,000 characters here, my logic would not change,
I'll just use first three positions in the array.
I'm just trying to show you something. And at the
end of this particular function, when we are done
using this array on the heap, we are making a call
to the free function, passing it the address of
this memory block this array see, our program
will just work like before. But let's run this
and monitor the memory consumption once again.
Once again, I'm showing you the task manager
and I'm playing the game. Let's make some bets.
Now watch out the memory consumption of game dot
txt. For howsoever Long You will play the game,
the memory consumption will shoot up. As you can
see, it's 350 6k. And it's not shooting up for me
even after playing for a long time. And
it is not shooting up because we had used
free to D allocate the memory when we were done
using it at the end of the function. Remember,
we had created an array of size 10,000. And if
we were not using free then the memory would have
shot up like anything the memory consumption
would have shot up like anything. But because
we are freeing at the end of the function, it's
not going up there is no memory leak. So finally,
to summarize it, memory leak is improper use
of dynamic memory or the heap section of memory
that causes the memory consumption of our program
to increase over a period of time. Remember,
memory leak always happens because of unused and
unreferenced memory blocks in the heap. Anything
on the stack is de allocated automatically
and stack is always fixed in size. At the
most we can have an overflow in stack. So this
was memory leak in C c++. Thanks for watching.